The tuna,
it keeps getting bigger.
Married.
His hips are this wife.
Oh,
I hate to tell you.
You're 35.
You guys are like,
oh,
it's awful.
You guys are alive right now.
Don't say anything.
Fucked up.
This episode.
We're talking about Brian's cousin.
Great for you.
Don't tell him.
Don't say anything fucked up by your
cousin.
He's.
He's just a kid.
Jesus.
I though I will.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you.
Buy naturebox.
Brian,
have you ever had delicious and
nutritious nature,
but not only that,
they sponsor the 10 minute podcast.
Sure.
Box.
It's actually pretty good.
It's great.
I,
I order you can order.
What I like about naturebox is that you
can order a specific stuff,
like I have them send me all gluten free
stuff,
so I got like the Serratia cashews.
Oh,
they're devastating.
And then there's almonds.
These blueberry almonds.
Holy Shit.
And they're fucking guilt free.
There's a lot of stuff that you can get
that you know,
it's more like pretzely stuff that
probably isn't the best for you,
but what they always have is no
hydrogenated oils,
no artificial colors,
no artificial flavors,
no artificial preservatives,
no transfats,
and it's really healthy stuff as far as
snacks go and depending on how you
choose,
you can get it very healthy.
Big Island pineapples.
Another great one I love.
It's their dried pineapple.
That's it.
It's just slices of delicious,
dried pineapple,
basically guilt free,
delicious,
awesome stuff.
And uh,
they also,
they'll ship anywhere,
free shipping anywhere in the United
States.
A naturebox is a,
just a great alternative to like if
you're working in an office and you
don't want to be forced to deal with the
vending machine food,
it's not that expensive either.
I think you can get,
like,
you can get 20 bags for 40 bucks or
something or whatever it is.
You can get 50 percent off your first
box by going to naturebox.com
forward slash rogen.
That's naturebox.com
They also have these chocolate almond
things are just fucking deadly.
I ate them all.
I eat everything.
I have a new package that just came.
I just get the ethos.
Those are naturebox.
Naturebox.com/Rogan.
Go there and save 50 percent off your
first box.
We're also brought to you by legalzoom.
Legalzoom is a way of handling all sorts
of things online that you would normally
have to go to a law office and meet with
a lawyer and pay a fuck load of money.
Most likely.
Instead you could do it at home,
drunk and naked.
You can be having sex and you could do
it with a laptop.
You could be giving head if you're so
inclined.
You could give head and then come up for
air every now and then and fill out some
forms.
I heard about legal zoom after they
sponsored my podcasts and I,
but way too late because I set up an
LLC.
It costs me $1,300
where you could have done it for like
100 bucks,
100 bucks.
I mean you can do it for 99 bucks.
You can set it,
you can incorporate or set up an llc for
99 bucks.
Someone told me you could do that free
online or that is like a bunch of steps
that you have to go through.
Legal Zoom makes it way more convenient.
It's just a hundred bucks.
Fucking Weirdos.
I get it.
It's a lot of money,
but it's way better than going to a a
law office.
Also.
I'll law and by the way,
I don't think that's.
I don't think it's true.
I don't think you can do it for free.
I think you have to do a bunch of
different things.
The way legal zoom has it set up.
It's way easier.
Fortunate they got,
first of all,
they got an a plus from the better
business bureau.
I love Shit like that so you don't have
to worry about it.
Plus I know a bunch of dudes,
Aubrey,
um,
formed on it,
the first llc for on it.
That was all done through legalzoom.
Brian,
when incorporated desk won,
that was done through legal zoom.
Not Add 10 customers would recommend
legalzoom after they used it.
But you know what that means,
that means it's awesome because we all
know one of 10 people are just whiny
cunt.
That's complained about everything.
So if you get nine out of 10,
that's beautiful.
If you really can make 90 percent.
Everybody on the Internet loves to,
loves to find anything to talk anything.
God.
If the aliens come and read our youtube
comments,
they're going to get right back in there
fucking spaceship and fly away like this
is just tough.
Called sucks is a cauldron of cunt.
Anyway,
with legal zoom,
you can get a last will for 69 bucks.
But.
And also they can provide you with the
third party attorney if you panic.
That's a big one.
So if you're in the middle of filling
all this stuff,
it was like,
oh yeah,
if I can do it,
they can hook you up with an independent
attorney so someone can figure it out
for you.
Cool.
Yeah.
Legalzoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you with a third
party attorney and provide you with self
help services.
Anyway.
Go there.
Use the Codeword Rogan in the referral
box at checkout and save yourself some
cash son.
Get it all together.
Bitch.
Last well for $69.
That's so depressing.
It's all the pressing death is
depressing,
but yet inevitable.
And so the stunt,
the sun itself has a billion years left
and then we're fucked anyway.
Whatever,
whatever on it.com.
Oh,
and it,
if you've never have you used any of the
onnit shit and we sent you anything.
I don't know.
My primal bell.
Give me an address.
I'll have it all sent to you.
Men.
Yeah,
please.
Give me the dress.
We have this new things,
warrior bars there.
Um,
by the same people that made the Tonka
Bar,
which is a native American recipe of
without any preservatives whatsoever.
Mixing cranberries and buffalo meat.
Each one of them has 14 grams of
protein.
It's no nitrates,
no artificial flavors,
no antibiotics,
no nonsense.
I'll be honest with four grams of fat.
I hate it.
And it was so good.
It's fucking delicious.
I gotta be honest.
I feel like I'm in the Truman show right
now.
Was that?
Have you ever seen that with Jim k
product placement,
but this isn't product place with him
and you guys love this stuff.
It's fucking delicious.
What was the.
What happened in the Truman show with
product?
The Truman show where the whole world's
watching Jim Carrey.
Yeah.
That's what the one where he is.
She's like,
try the nestle.
Quik.
It's delicious and refreshing and he's
like,
all right,
matt it to the store.
Well that was like,
he didn't know.
Right?
He had no idea that he was the show
since.
Since a baby.
I didn't see that.
It's a mind for man.
It's a mind.
Fuck.
You remember that Matthew mcconaughey
show?
It was a movie where they followed him
around with a camera and he became
really famous and we became like this
huge disaster.
It was called.
Was it called?
What?
It was called MTV,
MTV,
MTV.
That standard operational procedure on
reality shows now like those are real
and I watch every one of them.
This was before any of that.
Tell them your favorite show.
I mean,
I don't know where to begin.
Naked.
Love naked and afraid.
Let me just get through this audit thing
real quick.
Sorry.
I'll send you some shit,
man.
I'll send you some shit.
I'll send you a and I'll send you some
primal belts with the bulletproof coffee
because I make it myself.
You know what I'm saying?
Yourself and that's what I've been
doing.
What do you.
What do you mean,
like hookup with what?
With the kind of coffee?
Yes.
See we found out this is a.
We actually talked about the fungus came
out some bullshit.
Yeah.
Well this is the deal.
All right.
I don't know.
I can never.
I don't.
I don't want to speculate anybody's
intention.
So what I'll just tell you is the
absolute facts.
There have been cases where mycotoxins
became an issue with coffee.
Those cases,
most of them have been resolved by going
through these mycotoxin issues and then
rigorous testing and then figuring out
ways to not provide an environment where
mycotoxins are toxins and hopefully
heard that and took it and ran with it.
Good for you.
Here's the issue here,
but he stopped.
He brought me.
Unfortunately,
he brought me in,
unfortunately me because he was,
you know,
saying it on my podcast and I repeated
it without any research.
It used to be an issue and it can be an
issue still if someone is not preparing
coffee correctly,
but it's like when you buy really good
coffee,
like there's a company called Rusty's
Hawaiian delicious,
delicious coffee.
Their bags are rated by like coffee
connoisseur,
sores were professional coffee graders
that will taste the coffee and check out
various various beans and different
roasts and then they grade it,
but they also tested for mycotoxins.
Like if you have fungus in your fucking
coffee,
you get a really low score.
Fungus on my roast.
They figured out a long time ago.
First of all,
this is where it gets really weird.
That coffee was originally established
in Ethiopia,
which is a dry climate and all these
mycotoxin issues happened when they
started moving them out at Ethiopia,
put them in other places where there's
moisture.
Yeah,
exactly.
Growing them in different places.
In California,
wines have very few microtoxins,
especially Okra toxin a,
which is the big one because it's so
dry,
so they actually have very,
very little of that.
A very little issues with that.
Yeah.
Isn't that interesting?
And corn as well.
Corn,
you know there's.
There's a bunch of different mycotoxins.
That's the point.
If you buy really good coffee,
which is most of you,
what you buy,
most likely you're not gonna have any
issues whatsoever.
If you do have issues.
According to Dr Rhonda Patrick,
she was saying that even like above
threshold doses of these mycotoxins even
provide a beneficial reaction by your
body that your body reacting to these
mycotoxins that aren't necessarily like
really bad for you in small doses,
that your body might actually energize
it's immune system in response so it
might have some sort of a corresponding
positive effect.
This is obviously layman's terms.
I'm a retard.
I don't really even know what I just
said.
According to her,
these things make sense.
So what I'm saying is you can make that
style of coffee like coffee with grass
fed butter and mct oil.
You can make that with almost any good
and you're blending it or you're just.
You're just stuff that you're drinking
right here.
Is that delicious?
I don't ever plan.
I just.
Black coffee scoop of butter.
That's cool to t and start.
That's fine too.
I mean it's a little more.
A little Stevia can use the packets
though.
This bottle.
Oh yeah.
A little too much in Jack.
You if you only let,
like a mist of Stevia is a plant extract
zero.
Zero sugar.
You don't have to worry about it.
No,
not at all.
I mean,
it's probably like all things not great
if you ate it all day,
you know,
even plants,
I eat it all day.
I feel great.
Nine plants.
Our plants are toxic.
I mean quite a lot of their own tie.
They keep people from eating them
discouraged when people are like juicing
lots and lots of leafy Greens.
We'll do that.
We'll do that again.
About the rest of the commercial was
just keep going.
We don't have to play music.
Fuck it.
Just.
I liked throwing one out like that over
on a.com.
Use the code word.
Rogan saves money.
Yep.
Yeah.
Um,
so this is the point is that this,
this,
these toxins may or may not be an issue
in some coffee today.
They were at one point in time,
but the coffee experts aren't worried
about that.
When you talked to coffee experts,
they're all worried about taste and
flavor and where they're grown and
they're also worried about the fact that
the climate in Ethiopia apparently is
deteriorating because of global warming
and they think within the next 50 years,
like a good percentage of the species
that only exists in Ethiopia will be
extinct.
Wow.
Yeah.
Because there's all of the coffee in the
world comes from Ethiopia.
Originally my brother told me about this
and I was like,
Hey,
you realize in 50 years coffee is going
to be no longer freaked out.
I freaked out.
Well,
will start storing comp.
It'll be in Latin America,
Costa Rica.
Right.
That doesn't also matter like when you
roast them versus when you drink.
That's another thing that issue that
people have with this,
uh,
upgraded coffee.
Although it's,
you know,
he's very successful at sells very well
for whatever reasons.
Um,
so it's hard to keep on the shelf so
it's constantly moving.
So you're getting fresh coffee when you
buying it.
Caveman coffee roasts it when you order
it,
if you order caveman coffee when you're
playing right?
Tate Fletcher and really good coffee and
tested mycotoxin free 100 percent.
They tested it.
They went through.
They're getting everything single source
from a grower.
They know the guy,
the guy's family lives in South America
and he lives in Albuquerque,
so they traveled back and forth to the
farm.
They know exactly where it comes from.
It's as legit single source is.
You can get keith
guardians a bad ass coffee,
sweetie.
He's just a great guy and he was a hell
of a fighter,
you know,
and he still wants to go out and again,
he's thinking one more time,
one more time for Albuquerque when
they're trained with them for a long
time.
Right on time.
Yeah.
Really good friend.
He's an awesome guy.
Just couldn't be a cooler guy and he's
doing really well with this.
This caveman coffee company.
It's just they,
uh,
you know,
him and tate are big coffee,
banana and coffee take never goes
anywhere without a fucking container of
coffee.
Like everyone else carries a thermos of
He loves it.
Always has.
Ever since I've known him,
I had a guy on my podcast,
a what the hell?
I can't remember.
Sorry.
Hey,
he wrote a book called what?
White people?
No.
And uh,
and what white people do.
He started as a blog and he said one
thing about white people,
they are into their coffee man.
Like,
I love it.
My coach Tony Jeffries was like,
you're the only guy I know who drinks
coffee in between rounds.
I'll get a big,
a big cup of coffee and drinking in
between.
Right.
That's hilarious.
You know,
Tito told me that the coffee fucks with
your cardio.
He says he doesn't drink any.
It doesn't take any caffeine.
So Cardio fucks with your cardio.
I've heard different.
Now if your favorite says,
I'm going to listen.
No Shit.
Tito Ortiz tells me that I was with Tito
two days ago in a bar in by accident.
Lori sat and he,
it was his cheat day and he was drinking
a Shirley temple,
like literally in this really girly
glass,
so here's this giant to drinking a very,
very pink drink.
I was like,
that's Hilarious,
man.
He had tremendous cardio.
Tito's cargill to take Abbott Strength
Coach tells me not to drink caffeine.
I'm going to list.
You know what I'm saying?
There's,
there's certain people you need to
listen to what works for you man.
His Cardio is insane.
Crazy.
That fight where,
who was the fight where the guy got on
his back?
Well,
within the first minute of the first
round,
like there was like solid,
reliable,
ramble able to Hilo,
but that's obviously not him because
apple tree hill is the bad ass.
A welterweight that,
that name stuck in my head.
Well,
let's just look it up.
The Guy got right away.
Right?
And they're like,
just exactly where your ride doesn't
want to be tough.
He's,
he's been,
he's been done it right.
You know,
like did you see that able to Hilo,
Jamie varner fight.
That was fucking insane.
What a crazy slugfest slobber docker.
Oh my God.
I don't know why I thought why able to
Hilo was my name was coming into my
mind.
I got to pull up the student's name to
find out why that was.
Oh,
Uriel Contra.
So it was just another cool name.
Yeah.
Brian Callen isn't it really?
It's too much about,
but the pace that uriah put on that.
Uri,
I'll contract guy.
That's.
I wish I was a little guy.
If I was little.
I mean I feel like I should be a member
of team Alpha male.
I love long distance running.
I love eating healthy.
I love dieting.
I want to be a small guy.
Well,
you're very fit to for heavyweight.
You have like some pretty extreme
endurance for for a heavyweight.
Do you say that like what's going today?
Like with
a guy like Travis Brown or with guys
like John Jones or yourself,
you getting a lot of people that were
athletes in other sports that were like
high level athletes and then
transitioned over into fighting.
So in the beginning you're seeing like
they're learning.
They're really good athletes so they
move quicker than most people.
They usually have a little bit more
physical explosion power than most
people,
but then it takes them awhile to get all
the techniques down.
Now we're seeing like a lot of those
dudes,
but this is that we're seeing Osp is
another one opens.
I would say a lot.
I think we're seeing a number of them
starting to transition,
but the thing is,
I know I've done with tons of nfl guys,
Mba,
when someone's trying to hit you in the
face and you're just not.
That's why it takes so long.
I think for these athletes to adapt a
fighting because getting hit in the
face,
it's just,
it's just not either.
You were born where you're like,
yeah,
this is cool.
I can live with this.
I can learn.
Learn to get out of the way and you
know,
put my life on the line.
And then usually when guys are that good
of athletes,
like,
forget this,
forget this man,
isn't it?
I think,
I think you look like at the UFC and
guys starting to come around,
but people think to me,
you know,
in 10 years we have all these freak
athletes.
You're not man,
because he's freak athletes.
It's very rare you get a freak athlete
who's like,
yeah,
I'm going to go fight another killer in
a steel cage.
That's a very interesting point.
It's a very interesting point when
there's options to write,
especially,
especially when you're that good of an
athlete and you're making way more
money.
Well,
not necessarily.
Not necessarily.
You know,
it depends on what level you're fighting
in the UFC,
you know?
I mean,
if you're a guy will say about this all
the time,
like,
oh,
you guys don't get paid yet.
I make a great living man.
Yeah.
It's not true.
The first one.
No,
no,
no.
Hold up.
You're talking about the.
You're talking about the exception.
I make more than a Lotta yes.
Well,
here's what you have to understand.
When you look at pay,
okay.
Like there's pay that's listed like a.
As far as like the purse that you get
admission,
they list out what your staff does not.
That doesn't take into account a lot of
factors.
There's a lot of things that they want
to remain private so you're.
You're not just getting paid that
amount.
Some people are,
some people are just getting paid that
amount,
but guys you don't know that probably
should begin paid that amount,
but when a guy is selling tickets,
you know someone is a big name fighter.
There's a lot of factors in there is
there's well incentives.
Paperview pieces of paper for sure.
Like George St Pierre was making
$5,000,000
a fight.
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
Let's make it a lot of fucking money and
you know,
he's got sponsors.
You said Gatorade,
all this other stuff.
All this other revenue coming in and
George St Pierre made a load of money
fighting so maybe maybe it didn't make
as much as floyd mayweather,
but guess what?
Floyd Mayweather.
Floyd mayweather is one a bigger star to
a better promoter.
He's a fucking.
That doesn't matter what a guide and
there's that.
Well,
social UFC now use is pretty worldwide
now,
but it doesn't.
You could be.
There could be a spectacular fight in
the UFC,
a crazy epic fight that everybody wants
to see.
That could do one and
a half million,
2 million pay per view buys.
That's what floyd mayweather is done.
It is possible.
That could happen.
When you think about before Floyd Floyd
Mayweather,
it was.
It's hard to find like a guy since Oscar
de la Hoya,
maybe manny Pacquiao a guy who can do
like.
There's only a few of those guys,
like everybody wants to say,
oh,
in boxing they make so much more money.
No,
there's about five of.
You have those guys.
You're talking about the exception.
People always refer to the exception
mayweather Pacquiao or the exception.
Look at the.
If you watch this,
this last fight with Bradley,
look at the undercard.
It was pure shit.
It was horrible.
Those guys are scrapping.
I thought it was a good fight.
I thought.
I thought the undercard was pack.
Y'all Bradley's pack your bag.
That was good.
That was a really good.
There were some good fights in the
undercard.
It wasn't bad.
I enjoyed it.
Who was your favorite on the undercard?
Uh,
I'd have to look at it.
Exactly.
That's my.
That's my,
that's my point.
That's the problem with lots of no one
gives a flying hoot about the underdog.
No one just no one gives a shit because
you don't know him.
These guys are super talented and
they're not making any money on time.
You okay?
Here it is.
At a certain point in time,
there's only so many fucking room room
for so many fighters you can keep in
your head.
Put boxing,
boxing.
I mean,
let's go.
at heavyweight especially,
you got clear.
Listen,
Klitschko could probably deliver pizza
next door and no one's going to ask for
an autograph.
Isn't that weird?
That's crazy,
right?
That's was so dominant that your
heavyweight champ.
No one gives a shit.
That's so weird.
I find people were tweeting about the
under under crowd.
They were tweeting,
being defensive about the,
that the,
uh,
the uh,
hbo commentators were being defensive
about the quality of the undercard.
So maybe you're right,
I just tuned in and I may or may not
have been high as fuck.
So I had a good time.
I was white boxing fall by the wayside.
This isn't really.
It hasn't.
That's a misconception.
It hasn't fallen by the wayside.
It's just there's only a few guys that
can sell big pay per view.
Right.
Like maybe you know,
there's maybe like four or five guys
that can sell.
They don't.
Tell me one story.
Look at the UFC.
There's a countdown.
Every damn Tuesday.
Wednesday on billy.
Billy Billy's mom passed away and he
decided to turn to fighting the UFC does
the best job of marketing.
It's guys.
There was one fight that was actually
really good vargas versus that.
A Russian cat.
Yeah.
That was a good fight.
They were both on the feeding.
Yeah.
That was good for.
I was a very good.
Again though,
we're talking about that dude versus
Russian.
Do these motherfuckers,
man,
beast Russians that are making their way
into mma now,
making their way into boxing now.
It's really fascinating how many bad ass
Russians.
It's just living in the area.
Animals.
Scary really well,
it's also the epigenetics,
you know,
they're.
They're saying that now that people who
have had family members,
this was something that's passed down
through sperm.
They believe traumatic events through
your ancestry or passed down through
sperm and people who are children,
people who were the children's children
and children of people who have survived
traumatic disorders or traumatic
incidents were more likely to develop
all sorts of mental problems were more
likely to be like schizophrenia,
like all these,
all these issues,
mental issues that they could directly
correlate possibly to the trauma that
their ancestors have established.
Now think about how rude you are.
If you're little,
if your little kenny grown up in Malibu
and you want to be a fighter,
good luck competing with those guys over
in Siberia.
Yeah,
no,
I'm going to turn them back now.
You're fucked man.
Just forget it.
We're just hungry.
They have different jaws.
They're just different.
Look in there and playing.
Grab ass with fricking Bruce Jenner.
Meanwhile,
this Guy Barry,
a fricking wrestling.
That is hilarious.
Who's that?
Golovkin Khaled can congest triple g.
he's the next big star.
He's big,
he's a fucking animal.
He really is.
Body shots.
No one wants to fight them.
I'll tell you what,
I'm excited for the Sergio Martinez and
Miguel.
Miguel cotto has been looking very good
and his last few fights and Martinez is
almost 40 at a certain point and with
his style,
very different style than Bernard
Hopkins.
You know,
Bernard Hopkins,
Forty Eight fucking years old.
Crazy.
Still out boxing the shit out of Sergio
is all about footwork and some point
during that footwork goes away.
He's gonna get in trouble and his left,
he's got a brutal,
brutal lefthand and it's.
He mean he comes in with everything.
He's so good at his movement and his is
in and out movement.
He uses that same in and out movement to
land but devastating.
This is what we're talking about.
Fear.
So He's almost 40.
He played soccer almost all his life and
then got into boxing I think at 28.
Twenty nine.
No.
Yeah,
multi-time world champ.
No matter when you start with your Tito
Ortiz or veto for starting at 18,
19 year old or your Sergio Martinez
started at 30,
no matter when you start,
your clock is ticking.
You have this amount of fights in you.
No matter when.
I mean,
yeah guys drag it on,
you know,
via a fade or a cro.
Cop guys are drag it on,
but you're only going to be in your
prime and you're going to have these
many great fights in there.
It doesn't matter when you start talking
to eve Edwards about that.
He's 37 now and he's,
he's.
He was saying one of the frustrating
things for fighters I think is that you
learn the art.
You,
you continue to learn.
There's so much to learn,
but you continue to learn and then you
get to be 37,
38 and you may be a step slower but you
know so much more so you just want to
try it out.
But the game is also timing and speed.
And guess what?
That's why it came about because those
37,
38 year olds are like,
Dang,
I know so much man,
but my body's not the same.
Let me talk this doctor over here.
Now we have epic.
Dammit.
Now we've got big data.
It's not an episodic.
It's an epic.
No,
you're right though.
In Brazil,
spinning back,
kick in,
people's faces off in Brazil.
All T are teed up.
Joe Silva said it best.
He goes,
it's like [inaudible] or downloaded a
taekwondo black belt.
All of a sudden thrown.
We'll never,
never to a wheelchair and then knocked
out.
Luke rockhold.
Luke rockhold is a beast.
I mean for him to do it with ease and
then bisbing what?
I think you nailed it.
What you nailed is exactly what it is,
is that these guys get older and they
get so much more experienced,
so much more knowledge,
but that's the nature.
Balance.
Nature gives you that experience and
knowledge so you can teach.
It's like the two old.
It's like the two old buffalo,
the old buffalo in the young boy and a
cat.
I don't know this too on the calf.
The calf goes,
what is it?
Buffalo,
the young girl,
the young bomb y'all bought and the be
buffalo.
Let's go buffalo.
Yeah.
He goes,
he goes,
let's go down there.
Fuck all those.
Fuck one of those cow.
No,
no,
no.
You fucked it up already.
Listen,
this is what he says.
Listen.
He goes,
let's run down there and fuck one of
those cat.
And the old bull says,
let's walk down there and fuck them.
All right.
This is the other thing though.
When when these I get it to me and you
were still going to fuck it up.
Fuck,
this is the thing though.
Or bell form those guys.
The sport wasn't as big when they were
when they were superstars.
Right?
And now they're like,
whoa,
the sports huge.
I can stick around and take this stuff
and make all this money and be relevant.
You know what I'm saying is there's
vituro show that again,
Jamie,
look at this.
Look at this.
Oh,
that's not just doing that.
It's doing that to luke rockhold.
Who's better looking in Brendan Shop?
Maybe easy.
Now,
let me tell you some muscles on his
teeth really does.
Let me tell you this though.
Luke rockhold flew for 17 hours from San
Jose,
California,
showed up on a Saturday night.
Got We'll kicked in the face and jump
back on a plane.
That's got to suck.
It does suck.
I thought.
No.
Garren Brazil.
Can you tell Joe to the story about the
other stuff?
Are you allowed to about which one?
What other stuff?
Money Jersey.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Tell us why,
but they're secret.
They're not really for sure.
Quit eating those nuts because that's
fucking fucked up my whole game.
Yeah,
stop all that.
Before we tell any story,
I want to go back to this trt thing
because we can't just gloss over it like
that.
No,
no.
It's a huge subject.
I think you nailed it though too,
and you did too.
Talking about Eve Edwards feelings of
all the knowledge he's acquired these.
That is.
That does seem to be like nature's
balancing act,
right?
Yeah.
Like nature doesn't want you to have all
that knowledge and all that and live
forever.
It's like God saying,
no,
you got it cool.
Oh,
your body sucks.
You can't do it anymore.
Well,
it's sort of like the beauty of
everything is that it's temporary.
Like what's,
what's our favorite thing?
Let's be realistic.
Sex.
Most people's favorite thing.
It's sex.
When you're really horny and you're
having sex with someone who you really
like having sex with,
it's one of the greatest things on
earth.
One of the great things about,
as you know,
it's not gonna last you got,
look,
if you're a seller,
did you're great.
You'd be bored of it.
That's why guys do drugs and stuff.
See,
this is the people are freaks and
they're just fucking.
Their pupils are this big and then they
never opened the fucking curtain.
Those people are taking the same concept
with sex.
He's like,
man,
Yo would make this even better if we did
molly on this.
Yeah,
well those same differences like
fighting,
but you know,
it'd be better if I did steroids,
so this is a good point because the
molly thing,
if you do it on molly when all that
stuff wears off,
which it will wear off eventually you
are because you,
you're in debt,
you're like a kid with a student loan.
Like you started out of the gate,
like you're not belonging to us on
sesame street.
Just super dally paid way more than you
have.
It's like seeing what you see.
Those people who are just like,
they're now they're 53 hanging around a
coffee shop with a ponytail and really
have a job to try and try and get things
out and you're like,
oh,
you had a really good time for 15 years.
That's the same with fighting some
fighters.
I'll meet some fighters who are so
punchy and there may be 40,
45 for 15 years.
This guy was the man I wanted to be him.
Now I look.
I'm like,
dude,
you make me never want to fight again.
What were you doing?
Do you have a number in your head where
like you're,
you're,
or a place in your head where you're
going to reach,
where you're like,
that's it,
whether it's an age number or whether
it's a physical number,
does a gut feeling that you're gonna
have when you know,
when the hanging out?
I think,
you know,
I think you know,
but do you know the problem people ask
me this now,
people you know,
when do you think,
you know,
I probably say I have a good five years
left,
especially the way I train.
Right?
Brian,
you know I don't have an off season.
I'm in shape year round.
I trained nonstop around year round.
Do you do that to continue with your
improvement or do you also do that in
case someone calls,
like in case you get a last minute
justice just to get it,
just to get better,
just to get better.
Continuing to improve.
The only reason he's always dressed
well,
amen.
If that's the right attitude to have in
the hurt business,
you know you can't be casual about their
monsters out there.
And that's Mark Hunt.
I just called out Mark Hunt,
you try and listen to this.
He talks shit to me on twitter at 10:00
at night,
which is whatever time in New Zealand,
it's 10:00
and I read it like a whatever.
I'm watching naked and afraid or teen
mom or some bullshit,
right?
I'm like,
whatever.
Sitting there,
it's just killing me.
I'm like,
fuck this guy back on that.
I talked to him.
He bikes,
we're going back and forth.
Finally it was almost like,
you know,
like butter.
It just Bam.
Next thing I know I had him agree to a
winner.
Takes all fight and will fight in an
August winner takes all market,
Brenden's shop main event.
You're having a winner.
Takes all fine.
It was my idea.
So how does that work?
Like financially?
Like as far as like with the UFC,
the UFC won't sanction it.
Okay.
So him your purse when he's going to pay
me his porsche perse,
but.
Oh okay.
Yeah,
that's what I meant.
I was just say like Mike
and I,
you know,
it's just a proper way.
But the thing is you get all hyped up.
I had done with that sitting in bed,
my heart's going a million miles an
hour.
I just called out the whatever,
number five,
six heavyweight in the world,
the hardest hitter in the division,
and it's a winner.
Takes all fight,
not announced asleep.
You know what I'm saying?
Seven am went to practice.
No pressure.
That that was a Wednesday night and you
want to be a UFC fighter?
Fuck yeah.
The pressure's probably alien to most
people couldn't even fight week.
What?
Fight Week.
Depression.
You think about all the other avenues
you could have gone down to avoid
jumping into that cage for sure.
When you add everything goes through
your mind when all the other avenues in
life like,
yeah,
for sure.
I should be married with kids.
I can be wearing a suit and tie.
Got I got.
I'm a double major from history.
Colorado could be doing this.
I should've done this.
I could've done this blending.
Is that.
When does that go away?
A man pray,
right?
Right,
right.
When I get in the cage,
when I hit the Kratom cool.
In the back I'm like,
Hey,
what are we doing?
So once you hit the crowd then you like,
it's on your load and your body can
relax and at least it's going to get a
release from all this tension.
Yeah,
isn't that what it is?
It's like once the first round starts,
people would think like,
God,
it must be scary to fight,
but I would imagine that the most brutal
thing is just getting the buildup.
This building.
Oh,
when?
When?
When you're fighting.
You know,
in my last fight I was the Komen men or
second,
third fight.
In Toronto you'll see one 65 million
summitry own.
I mean we didn't fight till 9:00
at night.
You're waiting around all day thinking
about the fight and when do you eat?
It's tough for me because my nerves.
That's why everyone's like go shop.
She got two,
two.
Oh,
five lists on 252 pounds.
Right now the only reason I weigh in so
lights because I can't eat,
I can't eat.
So that's why.
Wow,
that's crazy.
I love reading because he gets,
he's so honest about it.
He calls out Alistair overeem on twitter
at [inaudible] and he's like,
he's like,
he stops and he goes,
hey,
God told him that.
He was like,
I gotta go try and hit the ground
running,
man.
Well,
that's good though,
isn't it?
Yeah.
So it was honesty,
honesty,
fear.
Oh,
people,
uh,
people all the time like,
Oh man,
you,
chuck Ladell is not like that Broccoli.
I hate to tell you my man,
your favorite fighters.
Just scared to admit it.
I'm not scared to admit you.
You know,
people are terrified back there.
You're going to fight another train
killer inside the octagon.
Basically in your underwear in front of
millions of people,
millions of people.
You can be a little scared.
I hate to tell you that.
I hate to tell you that man.
I hate to tell her.
How could you think to you when you're
fucking cool hand?
Luke was a good actor and he said,
there's a very,
there's a close relationship between
fear and intelligence.
He said,
anybody who's not,
who's not afraid at all,
as is,
I always go shake my head.
I got that guy's not very smart.
I'll tell you what,
Ken Kenny told me this,
tough fighters don't laughs.
Last smart
fighters do,
and he's right,
man.
That's totally right.
He's so.
He's so not hopkins.
Back to Barnard hop,
right?
Forty eight years old in boxing and he
talks clear.
You know,
I mean he doesn't have any insurance.
Very rarely gets hit clean.
Very rarely.
He might get hit cleaned two or three
times the same way,
right?
Very rarely use it.
Last guy to hit him clean with sugar.
Shane Mosley,
sugar Shane Mosley rocked with a right
hand and covered up,
recovered them boxes.
That instagram of sugar.
Shane,
between you and Tim Teebo,
he looked like you guys want them in
something like he's tiny.
Tell you what he was.
He was a tad punchy.
I'm not gonna lie to you a little bit
punchy floyd.
No sugar.
Shane.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
No.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Sugar.
Shane's a little,
little hunches.
He sees Bradley is going to be punching.
I've never seen anybody.
I've never seen him a take that kind of
punishment.
And do you think it's worth it?
Joe,
what about the prevent knockoff fights?
Did you see that thing I've ever seen?
He fought a fucking way.
Max Kellerman described it.
You took a Siberian caveman,
thought them out and then put boxing
gloves on them.
That's what that guy had slurred speech
for at least a month after.
Yeah.
He talked about it after the fact.
So you guys have kids.
Your kid wants to fight and they,
you know,
most likely there's going to be some
trouble down the road with his brain.
If he's a fighter,
you say,
cool.
You say you do whatever you want to do,
but that's what you want to do.
You have to be.
You can't have asset.
You can't have.
I don't want my kid to happen.
I didn't say lazy.
Muggy here.
If you want to do it,
if that's what you want to do,
that's what you should do.
I don't think anyone should do anything
other than that's gets to a certain
point until,
look,
that's what I wanted to do when I was
young.
I wanted to fight.
When I first figured out at a certain
point in time,
there was no future.
That's when I stopped doing it.
Well,
I'm worried about bringing made you
realize there is no fuel,
nothing in 1989 when my hand,
my last kickboxing match,
there was nothing.
There was no kickboxing,
taekwondo.
I couldn't respect it the way I used to
respect it because I started kickboxing
and I realized kickboxing,
you start eating it.
I fought above the waist pka style and
then I started training more and then I
realized like there was even more holes
in the above the waist time,
but above the waist pk style.
The.
The real problem was the boxing there.
I had done taekwondo for so long,
like my,
my hands were shit and my ability to
like move and throw kicks and punches
together.
It was all disjointed.
It just wasn't the right way to do
things.
Then when did you get into Jujitsu?
Ninety six.
It was,
yeah,
it was.
Y'All caught me at it.
So I,
I went through this period where I was
training like all the time in a martial
art that had all these holes in it,
so I wasn't ever going to go back and
compete,
like try to make the US Olympic team or
anything like that because I didn't feel
the same way about taekwondo.
I didn't want to just do it anymore
because I knew how easy it is for a guy
just cover up and walk you down and
corner you in a,
in a ring and fuck you up because you
don't know how to deal with hands.
It's just there was so many holes in it.
So it's so much easier to punch you in
the face when a guys were
throwing kicks and punches together and
you didn't understand like the rhythm
and the distance of punches.
So when I went from that,
like I had no choice,
there was no options.
But if there was an option,
like if kickboxing paid,
like what boxing does,
if there was a UFC option at that time I
would have had to learn grappling.
So I probably still wouldn't have
competed in the UFC.
If there was something like that,
like when I first started,
uh,
grappling when I first started Jujitsu
in [inaudible] 96,
I was amazed at how easy it was for
mended,
just raped me.
Just ragdoll me,
choked me,
Armbar me at will because I had,
they looked the same size as me.
Like they look pretty similar.
I looked at these people and I'd be
like,
well,
you're not bigger than me.
Like if I realize how vulnerable you
are.
Oh,
it's disturbing.
I think fighting,
like even learning a little bit of fun
and makes you more afraid.
Not less for more humble for sure.
So also don't you feel like at all the
pro athletes fighters are probably the
most approachable in the most down to
earth,
easy,
easy shot.
There's a reason why when a UFC fighter
goes into an event,
whether it's the sps,
whatever it is,
all sorts of stuff,
right?
There can be NBA,
Nhl,
nfl,
the WHO's who,
actors.
The room wants.
Talk to the finer because guess what?
No one was willing to do what a fighter
does.
So when a famous fighter walks in the
room,
he's the center of attention.
Every time,
man,
that's fast.
And every time when,
if there's Michael Jordan and like Uriah
Faber,
different store in Michael Jordan,
Michael Jordan's lithium now Muhammad
Ali.
Michael Jordan.
I bet you Muhammad Ali's going to get
some Jordan's mom.
I'll leave right now.
Who's on whatever when he was young.
Yeah.
How about.
Okay,
let's prep Mike.
Mike Tyson,
86.
Mike Tyson.
Mike doing.
I bet you more people go up to Mike
Tyson,
Mike Tyson and 86 taps into the street
and people would call their friends to
the fact that there's a man in the room
that can kill everybody with his bare
hands.
Yeah,
and that.
That's,
that's fascinating to met.
That's the John l Sullivan.
I can lick any man in this room,
but everyone.
When you're a kid,
everyone wants to be a fighter.
You're fighting your brother,
your kid.
The neighborhood.
Right?
What sports boiled down to the raw
element.
It's like the game you're playing is
let's play,
kill you.
Let's try.
You try to kill me.
I tried to kill you in.
Some of them are the game,
right?
Like football's a game.
Basketball is a game.
Listen,
if if Lebron James,
Mrs Jumpshot.
Hey listen,
he's going to go tomorrow.
If I missed the timing of Mark Hunt's
left hook,
listen,
my jaws will be shattered in 30
different spots.
I'm not fighting for probably a year and
a half.
That's the difference.
That's the stakes are a lot higher.
Way Higher.
Not even comparable.
It not comparable at all.
You could lose 20 basketball games in a
row and still go to the movies.
You imagine if you lost 20 fights in a
row,
not going to have a job.
It'd be impossible when you're
physically.
Well,
you know,
I was trying to.
Eddie Bravo and I were talking about
this.
This is a perfect way to describe.
One of the great things about Hugh Jitsu
is think about how many times you've
been tapped in your life in,
in Jujitsu.
I probably been tapped a 100 times.
Now.
What if I had been head
kick,
knocked out 100 times?
What if 100 times I got.
We'll kick like Luke rockhold.
Could you imagine a person who's been
wheelchair?
I'd be dead.
I don't think you could take full meal.
Kicks it back to those in your life to
have some problems.
You'd have nothing left.
You'd have literally nothing left,
but you can do that.
You can get rid of naked choked 100
times in a month and you're okay.
True.
You're going to be sore,
you're really sore,
but you're going to be okay.
And there's a big difference between the
teeth move,
but this is the difference in striking.
If someone's about to blast me with the
right hand,
I can't tap out and be like,
Nah,
we're good,
man.
Yeah,
you got that.
You got that.
That's good too.
If listen,
if you're going to get the guy who's
like,
if I get a of some,
I'm going to rip your arm up.
You're gonna be in trouble.
Some times,
you're not going to be able to roll
everyday.
Yeah,
that's the difference.
That's true too.
There's a way out.
You just do.
There's a white flag in boxing,
you know,
and these other sports.
There's no white flat.
That's why it's so crazy when someone
doesn't use that white flag and you
marched.
Her shit gets snapped like hands.
You're out for a long watch.
Sakharova break his arm.
Well,
that fight was over though.
How about tim?
Tim Silvia and Frank Mir.
Frank Mir snapped his forearm and half
earlier,
Tim Silvia's trying to punch him with
the left.
He knew something was wrong,
but he was like,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm just going to hit him with my hand.
I didn't see that.
Oh my God.
It's snapped.
Like the forearm was to stop.
No,
no,
no.
See,
pull that.
Frank Mir breaks the audience.
Didn't know what was going on.
So the audience was yelling and I had
explained to the audience.
Yeah,
I had to explain it.
I go watch it right here.
And the audience went,
Oh,
you've seen so much.
Watch this.
Watch the forums.
Yeah,
baby.
That's how powerful herb dean is.
A bad motherfucker.
He.
Yeah,
let's stop.
Stop,
stop,
stop.
He separates it and he's like,
Yo,
dude,
your arm is broken.
This fight is over.
You're doing the replay.
The audience was booing.
They were really pissed off.
I go.
Watch this right here.
Oh my God.
Frank Mir was one of my favorites.
Yeah,
my God,
that was incredible.
Arm Bar.
He's the only guy in the UFC,
by the way,
who's broken?
Two guys arms to high level world
champions arms and insane.
No,
Garrett and Frank Mir.
He almost ripped lesnar's leg apart.
Legs or last.
I had a normal size leg.
You know Masa Gotti fucked up,
man.
That was a bad listener.
Was tapping and they tapped again.
He taps some more and then finally the
referee stopped it.
Paula [inaudible] style for sure.
Oh,
if Paul Harvest got ahold of that,
he's.
Well,
he doesn't do the straight leg locks.
Cool.
Locked,
which is way more trouble.
Well,
he's doing insight helix.
That's his favorite.
He loves that inside.
He'll get it again to somebody.
Well,
he let go.
He let go.
You see?
Everybody is saying that he doesn't let
go.
They're going to jump on them.
No matter what he does.
If he gets submission,
they're jumping on him.
He absolutely is held submissions for
too long ago.
Absolute,
not just once,
many times.
There's fights of his in Brazil where
he's got a lock on a guy and he will not
let go in the referees.
Prior Anatomy.
He will not let go and I don't remember.
It was a choke or was a leg lock,
but he fucked that guy up.
I heard in training.
He's the exact same way.
You don't really only trains with his
brother,
his brother.
He doesn't do that with everyone else.
Like,
no,
I'm good man.
He hangs onto stuff that's so crazy.
That's so scary.
A guy who does that ridiculous.
Especially a guy who's built like that.
I mean she.
It's crazy how he is the biggest hundred
and 70 pounder I've ever seen anywhere.
Here's a smaller forehead than me.
Have you ever seen him?
Does we both have like my,
like my eyebrows are about to run into
the side here.
It's very similar.
Cro-Magnon,
so yeah.
Yeah.
He's.
That guy has the best leg locks man.
His leg locks were so finishing.
You know,
he grabs a hold of one.
It's like nine out of 10 someone's
tapping for,
except Alan Belcher beat the brakes off
belts or beat the British.
Totally.
Did he do it?
He he like willingly went into because
he worked in all of it and just post
them in the face to face.
Sat on top,
punch pass.
I should ask Alan and give props to
whoever coached him on his leg locks
there,
but Alan Belcher is a wizard at that
shit now because he prepared for that
fight and did everything every step of
the way,
like everything blocked.
Everything knew exactly what to expect
and you can see Paul,
her was just so flustered.
He really didn't know what to do because
Alan was like in right where he wanted
in this spiderweb defending everything
and then punching him in his face.
He says a little bit of an issue like do
there nate Marquardt when?
Yeah,
when they pulled out the leg submission.
He's like,
what?
What?
And then Bam blasted in the face while
he was accusing native greasing.
Leave that nate got out of his.
Well,
nate,
nate was pretty honest about what he
did.
He said I warmed up a lot because I knew
the guy was a really good at leg locks.
I want it to be nice and slippery,
so I sweat a lot.
You're allowed to do that for sure.
Yeah.
I mean there's no issue with that,
but he's like,
yeah,
he's like,
what?
And as he's pointing,
Nico's just dove on it.
It was great.
What do you remember that fight?
He fought Dan Miller and jumped up on
the catch and hit him and rocked him and
for whatever reason decided to fight was
over.
So he starts celebrating Pars case.
They pull them down from the cage.
The referees,
the fight still on like you have to keep
fighting like,
wow,
what are you doing?
Like did he end up winning?
Well,
I think you want to sit decision,
but it was one of the weirdest things
that embarrassing.
It's like he just decided to referee
stop real mccastle jumping up on the
cage.
Oh,
they're literally grabbing his shorts.
Were like,
Hey,
you owe me.
You're still going.
Paul hired.
Pull that up.
Paul Harris versus Dan Miller.
Um,
well if you could find it,
find the,
the,
the exchange because it's so bizarre.
Sweep.
He has an issue.
Obviously if you hear you read about
that guys,
childhood,
it was one of the most horrific
childhoods.
Oh,
that's it,
right.
That's it.
Is that look like he walks away.
He's on the cage.
You have to tear them down.
Yeah.
Let's look at the finish again.
Watch how muscular he is.
Dan Miller going to do it all the way
back to the beginning so we can see what
happened before.
So he hits him.
He had some boom,
boom.
And he just got,
he just decided.
He just decided,
look,
I live out.
Dan Miller's rushing over to them to
grab him on the cage.
What was he going to do?
Just those arms are.
So what does he weigh in there?
What?
80 five.
Well,
he weighed in at one 85.
He's probably,
you know,
two plus.
His nickname means tree stump.
Yeah.
And this one,
but it's terrible.
Carl and.
Oh,
his childhood.
Yeah,
his trial.
It was unbelievably horrific when he was
working.
Yeah.
He's working on a farm when he was a
little boy,
they eat pig slop,
like he literally had a pig slop,
like to stay alive.
We had no food when he first started
training,
he was just dirt poor,
as poor as can be.
This big scar on his chest.
Like they couldn't afford to take them
to a hospital.
So they glued it it like a giant gash on
his chest and they glued it together,
you know,
and when he was a little kid,
I mean he,
he lived a hard,
hard life probably filled with trauma
that people like us that grew up in a
nice neighborhood probably could never
understand again.
Kenny and Malibu,
who wants to fight?
No.
Macklin screwed bud.
Paul Harvey's is Super Glue in his ankle
walking pigs when he was eight years
old.
Yeah,
well we're talking.
We might've been talking about that.
Was that before the podcast or was it
during the commercial?
So we were saying that,
but it's the epigenetics thing that
scientists have proven that fear and
memory can be inherited via sperm and
know that when did that,
when did they,
when did they.
It's been a while,
but um,
there's,
there's papers that have been published
on it now.
Apparently researches began testing the
pups of traumatized dad's for a startle
response to different smells.
The assetto Fino don't settle.
Fino and stimulus had a big effect which
was not seen in the controls to
emphasize here.
These pups never actually learned any
previous foot shock trials to the set of
phone that the phone was bad news.
I guess that was evolutionarily though,
because remember Steve?
Yeah,
because Steven Rinella said you start
hunting and area the animals like the
elk in yellowstone because the wolves
are just introduced.
Their generation to generations have not
had to deal with wolves.
So what happens is they don't really
know how to defend against wolves.
They don't,
they don't have the built in several
responses,
etc.
But as they start getting killed by
wolves,
more and more,
their offspring will learn and it.
So it makes total sense.
So this is what happened.
They,
they use the smell of this chemical
which has a citrusy smell.
It's called a cdot finos and it was
paired with a slightly discomforting
electric shock to their feet.
So that's what they did to
the dads.
Then they gave the children of the dads
this set of fino and spray and they
panicked.
This is rats.
Mice,
mice.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
that's some insane shit,
man.
It's just joB is that whose job was
like,
hey,
you get the rats grabbed their feet,
man.
Who was doing that?
Well,
that's given these rat that.
That makes sense.
Evolution from an evolutionary
standpoint,
you know,
you,
if you continue to be haunted by lions
the first time at gazelle seas alliance,
it's running.
It's not,
it doesn't have to say,
hey,
what is that thing?
So my kids going to love coffee and
fricking thick chicks or whatever.
I think every healthy,
healthy boy likes thick chicks.
I was having this conversation with
women about,
um,
oh,
with the amy schumer about models like
the idea of a model,
like no one likes that.
No one likes that.
That's kinda what I mean.
It's not awful.
I don't want anybody who's really skinny
to feel bad.
No,
don't starve yourself to look like that.
I'm not doing anybody any favors,
but it's very rarely find a guy who was
like,
dang,
look at that girl.
I can see every rib.
It's like trying to take a nap in a
wooden chair.
Like,
no,
I,
I've never met a guy who just signed me
up for that skinny ass model.
Yeah,
yeah.
The girls have this idea where they need
to be that skinny guys don't like that.
Well,
it's gay guys who are fashion designers.
I'm not saying this trait cars aren't,
but a lot of them are gay.
Let's be real.
it's not homophobic to be honest.
There's a lot of gay guys that,
you know,
obviously they're not looking for hips
to weight ratio.
Waist ratio asked to waist ratio because
they're not thinking about fucking them,
you know,
so they like sledding,
but also,
but also go that cool looks,
that dress looks cool on that coat
hanger.
If we could get a chick to be that
skinny and thin so it'll look just like
that and then toss the blonde wig.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So the clothes.
Look the same.
Yeah,
so that's why I couldn't address,
but women,
they need models with blotter acid.
Women decide that.
Women who looked like that look good
though.
That gets weird for other.
Yeah.
They're told culturally,
you can be told like some tribes in
africa,
like are they in Burma?
Those women with a really long necks was
the women in africa that put the plates
in their face.
Yeah.
The bigger the playtime cattle,
you're worth foot binding in China,
you're,
you're.
You can learn cultures.
Learn what to track.
Yeah.
I'm just talking about like how weird
boobs and ask siri.
Yeah,
well that's the normal route.
That's the dna genetic,
but there's the cultural route.
What do you think it is?
Why guys are attracted to a bigger butts
and bigger animals?
That's a fact that they breed better.
Sure.
Larger breast,
larger asked me and she's going to have
more fat on her body.
She'll be,
she'll be healthier to take care of the
baby.
The is going to burn off a tremendous
amount of calories.
You want a healthy woman on a sickly
person.
You See her ribs,
that'll be unattractive because that
means she's starving already.
Cnn saying fricking eating amy
over here and then thick amy,
but there's a reason why guys like,
ooh,
look at those big ass titties.
Little ass too.
why is the healthy even animals,
male animals are attracted.
Round surface,
muscular.
You're also attracted to like a big ass
is like the sign of great genetics.
So it's just a reward speed.
But that power and everything,
but then even more than when a girl gets
surgery done and gets implants.
I'm sTill cool.
I'm game.
Yeah.
Cool.
you're letting your system get checked.
Tricked,
checked.
You're letting your system get tricked.
Like fake tits.
Yeah.
That's the thing with guys,
fake tits and fake gases.
They actually do work,
you know,
we're,
we're so pathetic.
Like our desire to just analyze it and
just get our loads out.
I know we're dealing with like,
um,
like pretend you were a ship and the
ship only had so much room for bullets
on it.
You know,
if you have too many bullets on it,
the fucking ship's going to sink.
Well,
every day a new shipment of bullets
arrives and you know what,
alright,
we're just gonna have to fucking be a
little less choosy with our targets.
Started shooting into the water in the
sky.
You got to get rid of bullets.
That's what it's like being a man.
Being a man is like being on a fuck
battleship that's constantly receiving a
new ship and uh,
bullets and you're looking at books,
they're looking at the fucking notebook
and you're like,
oh,
look at all those bullets we already
have.
Oh,
alright,
alright everybody on deck,
we've got to start fucking shoot in the
ocean again.
Everybody on deck,
all hands on deck.
All hands on deck.
People who don't fire off the rounds on
their own,
they're not judicious about that.
What happens to them though?
They get hoodwinked and some shitbag
relationship with some woman who
controls how they come.
You know,
I've,
I've had friends with her girlfriend
won't let them jerk off,
are you?
That's crazy.
I'll tell you right now,
my friend comes out and say,
have a good day,
sir.
We're no longer friends or race my
number.
Never call me ever again.
I went to Alaska and we came across so
boring with fishing.
Me and my dad lasted one day by the way.
Fishing.
Why?
Because I don't know how to fish.
We lost.
We lost every lawyer.
Every lawyer in one hour the guy goes,
we'll just put an alarm.
Will go,
oh no,
we don't have any more because you lost
them all.
Anyway,
I told this story of my past three
different point I'm making is that we
found a guy who had an arsenal he had an
art show have to do with chicks and
shooting about shooting gun.
Same thing when you have a lot of ammo.
He had crazy amounts of ammo and all
kinds of machine guns and I said I
couldn't.
I couldn't squeeze off enough rounds
like day after day kick,
kick,
kick.
I became completely desensitized.
I was trying to shoot everything.
I was like,
what's that thing in the water?
Is that an otter?
That's very different than what we were
talking about,
but I see why you can see what you're
saying.
See what type of bad correlation you
were talking about.
I,
I saw
a report where they say some guys.
Jesus,
what is that?
Who is that is?
I can sign me up.
Okay.
Is that a real ass?
Are you sure?
Are you sure you showed that hasn't been
pumped up.
Yay.
Hey,
guess what?
I don't care.
I do not care.
Okay.
This is my.
So yeah,
whatever.
Why is welby?
Let's make it.
She's probably not even real.
Life is probably a gigantic
hallucination in the first place.
Hologram?
Yeah.
Some sort of mathematical program from
space where we're on some computer
simulation,
but if that is the case,
you creating essentially everything with
your imagination that exists all around
you.
It's like you're literally live the
point I was a.
I saw,
I saw a report where it says you can
test trail where some guys are wired
where they just can't be faithful.
They're just not wired to be monogamous.
I wonder if that has anything to do with
the same thing that they're talking
about in this,
this story with a sperm being
transferred from father to son.
I wonder if that's the case with um,
because there's some things that they
say like the children of racists are
almost inherently racist,
not inherently racist,
like unavoidably so,
or they can't learn,
but they will tend to show racist
tendencies more likely than someone who
was an adopted child.
If someone who wasn't racist,
that's crazy.
Well,
I think they're trying now to figure out
exactly what makeS a human being.
We don't know yet.
So when you see something like this with
mice and you gotta think what's more
complex and mice or person or persons
way more fucking complex.
But if the underlying mechanisms like
this,
like what they're talking about in mice
does nothing for me,
but it doesn't because it would.
If you were a guy and you got mugged by
a black guy and a black guy beat the
shit out of you and took your wallet and
then you had a kid and your kid just
fucking shrieks every time it sees black
people.
I mean That is real.
That's the same mechanism that would
keep a look.
There's a reason why rupert sheldrake
had this analogy about a kids and
monsters,
like,
why is every kid afraid of a monster?
Even a kid who grows up in New York city
like you should be afraid of car
accidents,
right?
You should be afraid of floods.
You should be afraid of shit that's
real,
but kids are afraid of a monster in the
dark.
Why?
Because our ancestors get eaten by
jaguars.
Alright,
we saw way,
way back in the day before they figured
out houses and spears,
all that come made the people of today
and all that stuff's in there.
That's why some people have a video
phobia.
Some people have arachnophobia they're
afraid of snakes or they're aFraid of
spiders,
and it is fucking paralyzing.
If you've ever seen from an evolutionary
point of view of the state in this book,
why evolution is true,
why are people afraid of snakes?
And a lot of people inherently from all,
all over the place,
are afraid of snakes.
you take a fake snake on.
They've done these experiments right?
Where people are killed by cars way more
often.
Why?
Well,
primates,
when they see a snake will climb a tree,
almost like they're afraid of snakes,
so they think it's.
They think it's.
That's why they're still here.
They think it's an evolutionary memory.
Yeah.
that,
that human beings have carried from when
you know back back,
really.
They did a whole fucking research where
a guy listened.
Snakes are scary as share reason though.
I know he's panicking for a car wreck.
No.
You got into this thing where you're
trying to anti intellectualize the whole
situation and you like this is your
watch.
Esco.
No,
not at all,
Man.
Not at all.
No,
not at all.
There's a reason because a rattle snake
will bite you.
correct.
Shake his sale,
bite you.
How often have you seen ralph not even
know that I don't even know that name.
Date.
Declamatory.
Almost immediately they see when they
bite you.
Right?
But they don't know that we're talking
about things that have never been
exposed to snakes.
They don't have a book to read.
People that don't have videos to watch.
Just see us,
man.
I saY see a snake with these huge things
and they don't know what that thing is.
It looks like a stick that people have.
You don't touch a snake.
monkey of common sense.
Brennan one sense reminiscences most
likely rented common sense was be,
uh,
be.
Be afraid way more afraid of cars
because they kill way more people a
year.
Then do snakes.
Right?
But people we know,
we know cars.
People.
No snakes.
Not really what I'm saying.
That's why we're terrifying.
What are you talking about?
People don't know.
Snakes.
No,
they don't.
Wait a minute.
Come on man.
People don't know what a snake is.
Saw snakes taking my yard two days ago.
Well,
good for you joe.
You around rattle snakes all the time,
but everybody has an la la.
if you have a yard,
it's very possible that snakes are.
They don't know how many routes.
Thanks sir.
Zero rattle snake in your car.
Trust me.
You might not see a rattlesnake,
but they're out there,
but that's probably a very small
population in your neighborhood there.
The poInt I'm making is you're missing
the point.
Evolutionary scientists have to say,
I've,
I've realized that we have a natural and
a human being seemed to have universally
have a phobia of snakes and things.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
They have a natural phobia of snakes and
what that is probably as an evolutionary
memory,
and I'm talking,
joe was talking about how you have you
create fear memory through generations
and that is an example of that.
Whether or not you know you're afraid.
Snakes.
What the point is is that there are
other things in life you could be.
You should be way more afraid of him.
People are not because we don't have as
long a memory of it,
and that's the argument from the
argument.
I get both arguments then.
Why are people scared of aliens?
Well,
because they're scared of the unknown.
We're not just only scared of things
that we see that are scary because our
grandfathers got bitten by one.
We're also scared of the unknown.
We're scared of the dark period.
I think it's a good theory for sure,
and it makes sense,
but I think there's also some things
where,
listen,
you know,
if a predator walks in my room,
I'm be like,
hey man,
what's up?
Let's hang out.
No,
no,
no.
My children,
when you go like this to children,
they start crying little babies.
That scared me.
Why though?
Because it's a memory of being eaten to
memory,
of being eaten.
So what they found is even infants,
when you go,
when you bury your teeth and go like
this with your hands,
you go and grout,
low noises for infants.
That's why when men come into a room,
a lot of times children when they hear a
low voice,
especially when the person's talking
loud man,
they immediately are way more afraid of
that than they are of of a woman with a
high voice.
Why is that?
Why did they start crying?
It's strange men.
That is a.
That is according to a lot of
evolutionary biologist.
That is a memory that you were actually
born with.
Not in.
What's that called?
Instinct,
right?
I mean it's the type of incident or the
babies are scared because the giant do
talking all loud.
You just chalk it up to that.
They're not afraid of teenagers.
Why?
babies are afraid of a lot of shit.
They're afraid of things don't make
sense.
Like a ladies hat.
The fucking giant feathers.
They freak out because it's to get the
point you're making and I think it's
true,
but I also think sometimes you just know
I.
You know what I think?
I think it's not either or.
I think it's both,
but what they're saying in this study
and memorize what's been proven in this
study though is pretty unavoidable.
if they're.
They're detecting this stress response
to a very specific smell that they've
created that they associated with
electric shocks and then the the
children have that same reaction.
That's pretty much proof,
but then how's this go back?
The guy being faithful was saying is the
same thing with racism.
I was saying that there's things that
are even useless.
Things that are passed on from
generation to generation and I think at
least at one point in time there was a
time where the human race has probably
in jeopardy and it was probably
ridiculous for one guy to have sex with
one woman and hope that the race was
going to keep going.
Everybody fucked as much as they could
because half the babies got eaten by
jaguars.
I mean,
what are the odds of a fleshy little
fucking shitty designed human disease?
Survive animals,
wolves,
fucking everything you until you figure
out weapons.
Then you have to band together and that
doesn't work out.
Look,
it's a hard road for a long time for
people to make it this far.
Now it's so out of control that we're
overwhelming.
The population is overwhelming the
resources of the planet and will
continue to grow at this rate or have an
exponential rate,
but a long time ago,
man,
it was tough to keep people alive.
During the roman times.
It was a 50 percent infant mortality
rate.
Fifty percent.
If you had two kids,
one of them was going to die for sure,
and you just had to deal with that.
They're just having sex with whoever it
was.
Cool.
They were mad dog in it because they
were trying to keep the race alive.
You know,
one of the things that they found when
they were going over the dead sea
scrolls was that they,
the dead sea scrolls is the most,
the oldest stories of the bible that are
known.
It's the only form of the bible that's
written in aramaic,
and they found that in these scrolls in
Iran,
it was written on animal skins and left
in these caves and these,
these ceramic pots.
They found that a big part of What they
were concerned with was fertility
rituals.
They were concerned with making sure
that they breed,
making sure that they carry on.
I mean,
this is,
we're talking like thousands and
thousands of years ago.
We.
That's nothing though.
When you think about the fact that
humans in this form of essentially been
around for close to a million years,
so for a long time it was a hard
scrabble life where we might not,
might not fucking make it and the only
way we could make it is if we protect
our territory and fuck every chick we
can,
which is shooting and to everybody.
So miguel was like,
let's do this.
Those are the men that made it,
the men that made it,
the humans that made it were the ones
that had this evolutionary trait.
And it conversely,
by the way,
and you're saying that trades carried
on.
Yes.
Well that trade exists in primates,
but not.
I don't think it'll all.
I don't think to all.
I guess some still have it know it
exists in all primates.
Every single primary,
the only primate that it's ever been
observed to even try to be monogamous as
a human being.
All the monkeys,
the gorillas have harems and the
gorillas have such a domination over the
females that the females never cheat.
So because of this,
the grills,
dicks have shrunk the size of an inch.
Gorillas have tiny,
tiny little ball and the little chimp
pitches or whole ours chimps are sluts.
So chimps have giant balls and giant
eagle,
but not as big as humans.
Human beings are the most promiscuous.
And there's a direct correlation between
female promiscuity and male testicular
size.
Really?
Yes.
The bigger the balls,
the more likely the male is surrounded
by a bunch of hula.
The dick.
So your body recognizes this and the
the.
The competition builds up so you,
you come more,
you build up more.
There Was a bunch of faulty conclusion
reached by a book called sperm wars and
this book is basically,
there's a lot of junk science attached
to it and a lot of it was about these
killer sperm that attacks sperm and
killed them,
but they've never been able to
conclusively prove that sperm have any
properties other than trying to get
someone pregnant.
There's never been proven that their
sperm that are attacking other sperm or
any mechanism which they kill the sperm.
But what it has been proven is your dick
is shaped a certain way.
Okay.
And the big fat head at the end is a
goddamn plunger.
and like the evolutionary design,
a dude has got a little dickhead,
ever see a porn and the guy's got a
little head is poor bastard.
WhaT are you going to do with that
thing?
Exactly.
Because evolutionary,
we look at that the same way we look at
a big ass or big tits.
Like that's not a good design.
Like look at that little fat,
fat dick with a little head.
You're a mess.
You're not plunging a can.
My,
my,
my girl,
I'm not,
I'm not jealous.
You're plunging.
You'rE using this big fat dick head.
The bigger,
the better to squirt out all the other
dudes sperm.
And then with the hood of the books.
Hooker.
Yeah.
It pulls it out and then you shoot.
Your own is intense.
It's intense.
But that's the design of the human is
the plunger.
Yeah.
Everyone's book.
And that's,
that's really.
Are there any anteaters in here?
Do you want to have a hood hanging over
me?
no,
believe it is as well and tortured,
but in england most of them have the
hood.
I didn't know that.
Well,
it should be because it's gentlemen
mutation really is because my coach tony
jeffries in santa monica,
he's having a baby.
I said,
man,
if it's a boy,
you're going to cut the hood off,
right?
Like it's weird to leave it on.
And he goes,
no.
He goes,
who kissed her hood?
Off I go,
uh,
everybody.
Haven't you ever seen the scene that
you're better at it can't.
No studies,
no studies whatsoever.
All junk science shit under the,
you know,
a lot of religious thing,
right?
They taught it a little bit of a
religious thing,
but it's also,
I believe that they're preparing for a
giant backlash of babies have had their
dick sliced because if circumcision was
proven to be genital mutilation and
stopped,
then guess what?
You opened the door for suits.
If everybody just decides to go ape shit
on the american medical association or
anybody who allowed essentially a non
beneficial genital mutilation to norm to
be the norm or real.
Do you know what kind of backlash?
I mean,
this is not a propaganda or rather a,
a,
um,
a conspiracy theory,
sort of a,
an idea.
This is the reality of what's going on.
Genital mutilation on a wide scale
that's completely unnecessary,
that has no health benefits.
What,
what's weird is in a locked room,
nfl college locker room,
if you got a hood,
you were the outcast.
He made fun of your fund.
Your dick.
Yeah,
but tony was saying england,
if you didn't have a hood,
you got made fun of.
I bet it's weird,
right?
Well,
one's natural hair.
That's not right.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also about with the plates in the
lip and all that shit.
It's just whatever the culture decides
is the norm and the culture's decided
that cutting your dick to her house to
her of course.
So you have a better chance of not
contacting like a gonorrhea and things.
I think that's.
I think that's all.
There is no medical society in the world
that has recognized any real health
benefits to circumcision.
It's all bullshit.
Not only that,
the risks include infection,
hemorrhage,
scarring,
difficulty urinating,
loss of part or all of the penis,
and even death.
Circumcision complications can also and
do occur even if the best in the best
clinical settings.
Early producers back in a little too
smiley.
Oh,
there,
you got some hoods that more than maybe
this decade has more than one baby has.
This decade has died in New York because
the rabbis who,
uh,
these really heavy religious jewish
dudes insist on using the moyle who uses
the traditional method of circumcision
where they circumcise the baby and then
suck his penis to stop the
bleeding.
And these rabbis have had herpes and
given her [inaudible] to the babies,
they refused to stop this because this
is a religious procedure.
There's moyles online rabbis online.
they're doinG these videos on like the
jewish name for what that procedure is
and how it's written in the torah.
And this is why you should do it that
way.
And this is why it's a traditional way.
Yeah.
Could you imagine?
Here's the task that the universe has
given you.
Like we're on a,
we're all following different patterns.
Mean brian,
you've got a nice golf shirt on.
I have converse all stars well following
patterns,
right?
Here's the pattern.
The pattern is there's a fucking ancient
religion that was written back when
people thought the world was flat.
All the fucking rules are written down
on animal skins and fucking chicken
scratch that you can't even read today,
and it says you could suck baby dicks.
You cut their dicks and then you suck
them in humanity if that didn't exist
and you try.
Does that true?
Absolutely.
I will show you a video you want to see
a video.
Is that in the video with spraying
explains about a sucking a penis after
circumcision?
It's one of the most thing.
The internet or this is a no,
no,
no.
He told me to.
I talked to rob about it.
Who was raised incredibly religious.
Are he studied the torah 12 hours a day
and he was.
He watched all this shit and he said,
yeah,
what the guy is saying is true.
I don't know that it happened in the
things that John Duran who wrote the
paleo manifesto,
did my podcast,
talked about was the old testament with
the obsession of washing.
You know,
he calls moses the first
microbiologists,
the idea of a guy who they were obsessed
with keeping things clean.
I don't know.
Find out if the guys have been talking
about it being read the descriptions or
listened to it.
We got to talking about sucking on a
penis to up circumcision.
Rabbi sucking penis.
I bet you'll doctor.
I don't have any kids.
If I did and dr touching my kid's a
dick.
He's getting.
Well dr jack his dick to make sure
everything's okay.
This guy,
first of all,
he's not a doctor.
He's a religious nut.
He's a cult member.
That's what that guy is.
I mean,
if,
if there was no religious extreme,
not extreme at all.
If there was no religion,
if religion didn't exist and some guy
came along and dressed like a fucking
spaceman and wanting to suck baby
dick's,
he'd be like,
well,
that guy's in a cult,
but because it's around for a thousand
years,
it's not a cult.
Oh,
it's a religion.
Needs a fucking cult.
Anytime you can get people to adhere to
an ideology that you have to look to the
stars to find your fucking answers in
some magical man who has rules like not
mixing meat with milk and coupled with a
lot of those rules.
John duran,
who just wrote this book,
a lot of those rules were we're very
practical backnet not eating sugar
because because you didn't want to kiss
the kenosis exact sexual laws were know
the restrictions on sex where just
because you didn't want to catch
syphilis and things back in the day.
So there's no cutting and baby dick
sense.
I don't know anything about cutting,
cutting,
sucking baby dick,
all that.
Does
he know that comes from moses when he
cut his own penis to show his serbians
to god in the old testament.
That's a very weird way to show your
speaking.
So you haven't had a friend breakup.
Dick moses.
I heard of that before I've ever had to
rush into the emergency room.
Does it ever get fixed?
Totally.
Or is it always kind of hooked it kinda.
Yeah.
Curves to the left a little bit.
Wow.
His balls literally internal bleeding
filled up.
Oh look.
Like purple gecko skin.
That's why you've got to be careful with
crazy bitches.
You got to get double under hooks on
crazy bitch.
Crazy bitches riding you.
You gotta,
you gotta hold their ass.
But like,
uh,
from,
you know how you got to go?
You can't just do this because if you do
this,
there's too much lateral.
There's room for doubt.
Gable grip.
The lower hips.
My buddy is huge.
You've met this guy.
No,
you can say his name on there.
These guys.
Sixty six to 70 shred runaways.
Wait.
People are gonna.
Figure out who they are.
They will figure it out.
So he's like,
he tells me,
he goes,
bro,
this girl wants it so hard.
He was,
I don't know what to do.
I knew how hard he goes,
I'm going to film it next time.
So he films it and it's one of the most
disturbing videos I've ever seen.
I mean,
he's getting ear like why am like dang,
week later he calls me up,
dude,
get over here.
I rush over.
What's the.
He's on the ground,
but button naked.
What's the matter?
He goes,
that video I showed you.
I was backing up,
missed my penis,
hit her ass,
broke his dick.
Oh my god.
So thIs is what I tell them.
I go,
this is an easy fix,
right?
I,
I've,
I'm,
I have no idea how to hand this.
Dr schaub.
Yeah,
dr.
Schaub in the house.
Big brown.shop
in the house.
I know this is easy fix.
I'm going to step out of the room.
You put a little porno on,
you get a wreck.
We're just going to line it right back.
Right back up.
Just like you fix a broken nose.
That's a great strategy,
right?
Right.
Makes sense.
That's a great room.
Ten minutes later I hear,
I'm like,
oh shit.
So I called my doctor buddy.
I'm like,
yo man,
my,
my buddy was hooking up with this girl
broke his sticky as well,
is like,
you're his testicles big.
Oh yeah,
man,
they're pretty big.
Let me see your goes man.
Shows me these things are the size of a
grapefruit and it looks like ghetto
purple dotted.
Oh,
rush.
Dr.
Rush.
I'm the merchant cause internal
bleeding.
And uh,
people thought we were just to gays.
Gay men.
Big dudes.
I'm not making this up.
I wish I could make this up.
He straddled in a gurney like this,
right?
He's like this things hanging down.
It's filling up,
talking on about.
This nurse comes in,
hey boys flaming,
flaming gay guy,
right?
Which is whatever.
I'm cool with that,
right?
Legs up and straub if this is his broken
penis.
This dude's like this.
Yeah.
yeah.
This is pretty bad.
Listen,
we'll get a doctor and we'll be rigHt
back.
He's doing that to his boss and I'm
like,
what is going on in leaves?
Doc comes in,
old dude.
I'm like,
oh,
thank god dot comes in.
He goes,
yeah man,
this is really bad.
Or yeah,
the nurse was kinda,
uh,
you know,
he's grabbing a man.
It's insane how badly it goes.
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Nurse physically touched his penis,
touched telescope,
knows,
deepen his in his,
on his dick.
And he goes,
wow,
I need to get the name of that guy
because that is not code here that the
white jacket,
$500.
My wife has got an app on his phone and
when anybody gets administered in the
hospital with a broken dick,
you fucking shows up,
puts on his lap,
dances.
This urologist comes in.
I go,
I gotta be honest,
man.
How did you get into basically majoring
in dick's?
Like what role did you go down and he
Said in Egypt or someplace in Egypt
where um,
there's a religion,
they might be muslim,
I'm not sure,
but they get erections.
They think it's dealt the sentence work
and they break their debts.
Not in,
that's not muslim religion.
There might be.
Well no,
it's an extremist muslim.
He was saying it just sounds like a dumb
person who,
whatever it is,
it's another crazy cause he was saying
he and these guys need help,
so he got into it because he was exposed
to it.
So these guys think it's satan's work.
The devil's work,
they get erections.
Snap their day.
A lot of them died from internal
bleeding.
He had,
they brushed doctors down there.
So most urologists go down to this part
of the world.
That's a fix it guy.
Anyways,
my buddy,
my buddy got a break.
He's all good now.
The updated my friend.
All good.
They give him pills so he couldn't get
an erection for six weeks and his dick
was in a splint.
Really?
A splints.
Splints.
It just has a hook.
Yeah.
So I'd hook or a big one a.
Oh,
it's definitely knows.
What's that operation.
You can cut the tendon and it makes your
dick,
but it's nice Florida around your
tickets.
harden.
it goes straight down.
Sometimes.
That was the complication that.
How much longer could it make you got to
jerk off downward.
Huh?
How much longer could it make that
small?
Yeah,
and institutions,
you can cut the tendon that will
actually create more length here,
dick,
but the problem was that the,
for whatever reason,
the tenant is one of the instrumental
tenants and keeping it very hot,
you know,
rec.
You would thInk they would build some
sort of implant for that.
By now they have implants,
root thing else.
People are so fucking weird.
You're so weird that we'd be willing to
cut or a dick to stretch it out and you
know guys,
if you could get fake.
Dick's is like the way we're going to
get fake tits guys will be walking
around with fit 15 inch dick.
No,
they wouldn't because women wouldn't
want it.
See,
there's a big difference.
That's why guys aren't allowed to wear a
pays and guys and girls wore wigs.
We don't give a fuck.
Girls can have fake tits.
Who cares if a guy has fake shoulders?
That guy was walking around with fucking
fake shoulders and you're like,
oh my god,
I love your shoulders.
anyway,
scorned scorns.
They're like fucking fake taste like
that.
They sell shirts like that.
Yeah,
they do.
They sell shares.
You have looked into it.
I did a world's dumbest and they had and
it was one of the inventions that they
sell them and well that's theirs.
They have pants that women wear that
like suck everything tight to their ass
banks.
Yeah.
That's what made me millions,
but in that crazy,
like wilmington have fake tits when we
can have a lot of fake things are
extensions,
but it does not bother me at all.
We don't care because we're trying to
fuck as many of them as possible.
That's what the monkey dna wants to do.
So when the,
when the monkey has no problem wIth the
fake tits,
the like,
that's great for now let's go.
Whether they like it sticks out the way.
I like it.
But you know,
like your,
your dna so scrambled.
Whereas the woman looks at you with your
fake shoulders like,
oh this week,
shit,
mother fucker can't even grow a shallow
women.
Oh,
you're not coming in.
Make women want you to get the job done.
They want utility.
Men likes things that are static,
that look good,
that we can grab and fuck,
but women need to.
I mean,
I'm saying evolutionarily you,
I would imagine women need.
You got to go out there and actually
hunt something while I'm taking care of
the kids and if you've got fake
shoulders are going to help you catch
that deer.
You're like a weak person is not able to
completely look at reality,
but you can see a hot chick with a
pretty crappy dude.
You know what I'm saying?
You never get to see red plate looking
dude with a real fat,
ugly girl.
That's true,
but you will.
You do if he's gay,
but you do see you.
You also see like these guys that are
with these girls and the girl is like
way better looking than the guy younger.
Probably sugar daddy.
Yeah.
You see that a lot of times women are
attracted.
I would never date to go to something
like guys,
we're really good at something and he's
not that good.
Looking.
Women find that very attractive.
So you get a guy who someone's older and
older.
No,
I mean if you're like really funny,
you got really good skill,
man,
you can still get those young girls
there are wrong because billy who works
at the arcade,
who's jack has no skill,
she's going to take billy that works at
the Arcade over you as a skill.
You say that,
but then you see david spade with a
dime.
yeah.
You know,
becauSe he's funny and he's also rich
and famous and rich,
you know,
good at some famous,
tough,
famous,
different names,
different chicken head there.
A lot of guys.
Chicken heads coming there.
Not chicken heads.
What's that mean?
Chicken heads like girls,
just fame.
You know girl,
there's been beaus you know what I'm
saying?
Like oh,
chicken,
chicken heads.
But you said that as if we would know
what you mean.
Oh yeah.
I thought you would do.
I said ma'am,
chicken and I've heard him use the
expression before,
but it fresh chicken head is a female
who likes cock,
a female as giving head bobbing.
this is in the urban dictionary,
a dancing up and down like a chicken and
it's a dance move.
Well,
brendan shops got his own definition of
chicken heads.
I get it,
but if a guy can play the guitar really
well and he's not that good looking,
he's getting laid.
Amy schumer had a strange thing we were
talking about last night,
being a girl like she was talking about
how being a girl sucks because you have
an expiration date on the time where
people want to fuck you for sure,
and it's running through a clock that's
running from the moment you realize that
sex is important til nobody wants to
fuck you anymore.
Ready?
Go.
Tick tock,
tick tock,
tick tock.
I heard my grandmother talking about how
devastating it was.
The first time she realized men stopped
looking at her.
she said she.
She realized she was finally old when
she walked by a group of construction
workers.
One of them looked up and she said that
was when she was with other older women
and they all went,
yep,
I remember that day too.
My heart broke heartbrokeN.
I was about 15 or 16.
Man,
that's a tough.
That's a tough day at some girl.
Tell me.
Still don't,
don't waste my time because I'm in my
prime.
I have three more years left in my time.
I had a girl tell me a wasted wasted a
year of my life with you when I didn't
want to keep dating and was like,
okay,
now I got you.
Just totally let me know that I made the
right to say that I thought we dated and
went to dinner and had a lot of fun and
I thought like all my other friends,
I enjoyed your company.
I didn'T know that you were investing.
We're fucking their twenties,
you Know,
I was like 23 or something like that.
Jesus christ,
this is crazy.
A lot of girls are raised to think,
you know,
you've got it.
I'm even my own mother who's a really
smart woman,
said to my,
my sister,
when she went to get her mba,
she went,
hey lIsten,
you're going to get your mba.
That's great.
Work on your mrs as well.
You know what's on your mItten,
mrs.
Oh god.
I tell brian all the what we talked
about this,
talking about relationships all the
time.
I'll talk to brian like,
man,
I'm a little stressed out.
Should I be having kids are doing
something here,
showing me coming home and a life making
food and stuff,
and he goes,
no man.
That's what society wants you to do.
That's the norm.
That's what everyone wants you to have
this conversation with people who asked
me because they know I love having kids
and they'd go,
do you think that everyone should have a
kid?
If I didn't have a kid,
would I still be happy?
And I said,
absolutely not.
Everybody shouldn't have a kId.
I go,
you can be a great person.
Have a great life,
infect a great amount of people around
you.
Be a joy to be around.
Contribute every step of the way.
Be a a great example.
Inspire people and never have kids.
Hundred percent.
You don't have to hunt.
It doesn't make you better and,
but people take this goddamn self
righteous attitude when they do have
kids and I resent it and I have kids and
I love.
I love my kids.
I would never trade being a father for
anything.
It's a fantastic experience.
Have a kid when you are ready and have a
kid.
If you feel something from it or don't
or don't eat it,
it doesn't matter like it.
It's a great thing for me.
I enjoy,
but you don't have to.
I know a lot like my friend chris ryan,
dr chris ryan who wrote sex at dawn.
He made a conscious decision.
We as younger,
no kids.
He wanted to travel the world.
He lived in barcelona.
I mean he wrote books.
He decided he had a life that he wanted
to live for.
This pisses me off when people don't
want kids.
really.
My brother don't let kids and drives me
nuts because he loves them.
Give something back,
man.
You're pulling this earth to procreate.
Give something back.
Oh,
I don't know about all that.
Why you put on this earth to procreate.
Okay.
for the same reason,
homeboy before they're all dying.
Not everybody has that much to offer.
So some people,
some people may like,
how about somebody who is basically
unhappy with their life and they have
kids or if they don't have too much
stevie again,
that's.
Yeah,
watch how I do bro.
This is the stuff.
That's what I do.
There's more of these grabbiNg a whole
form towns and grab another one.
Man county.
Can I drink all this?
He doesn't even drink it.
He gave up already falling asleep.
I'll get them over there and I'm all
like sensitive.
I have one cup.
I'm like,
well,
I feel shaky.
I.
I know what you're saying.
You don't think that there's a good
thing to do.
When I like clothes,
I like shopping.
I like my vacations.
I don't want kids.
Why is that?
You know what?
Lose my number.
You're not my friend anymore.
How dare you,
but why is that bad?
Why do you care what other people?
I don't know.
That doesn't make any sense.
Especially if they're close to me.
You know what drives me?
Nuts,
man.
If people hate kids and something about
women hating kids.
I wrote this on twitter once that I view
women who don't like kids the same way
of your dogs like to eat their own shit
and then the cis male feminist guy wrote
this huge blog.
I should have said hate.
I said,
don't like,
so he connected it to the only reason
why women exist in his world is to have
children like they added a bunch of
stupid shit that I don't believe at all.
To reInforce this idiotic point.
You're writing a blog about a tweet.
You fucking idiot.
True.
You know,
that's,
that's what you're doing.
And by the way,
he's an academic to first of all,
for you singles out there,
red flags.
If a girl likes cat,
doesn't like dogs,
and then like kids.
Yeah,
I'll read,
carry on in some people's lives,
in some people's lives,
it's a good thing if you want to check
the doesn't like kids and you don't like
kids.
She don't like kids.
She's probably pretty selfish.
My man could be.
you're right.
No,
no.
Most likely,
most likely your she's into something or
she's just in tip.
She could be and makes $8 a day.
I mean,
who looks well?
Everybody has to want children,
but yeah,
it couldn't be some sort of a really
demanding occupation.
She handles really bad childhood or she
had a really bad childhood.
Okay.
And again,
you guys are talking about the exception
in general in general,
she doesn't like someone who has a
really good career or demanding career
today.
That's not really the exception that
much.
There's a lot of women who have very
demanding careers today.
Yeah.
And very fulfilling.
You don't run into them.
I do look at brendan just made the like,
I just farted.
You know what?
In la.
Yeah,
they're everywhere.
I meet a model actress.
I mean what you just said right there
from regular women.
I understand what you're saying.
Let's broaden our horizons and try even
though with three.
I'm talking from brendan shot in marina
del rey.
I'm not talking about finished the world
and brennan shop.
Marina del rey.
People that don't want to have kids.
Like,
fuck you.
Here's my number.
There you go.
She goes,
hey,
I'm kelly.
I love cats.
I've had cats.
I hate kids and I hate dogs.
I'm like,
cool.
Over red flag.
Well that's.
That's how that lack of not liking dogs
thing.
It's a weird thing because it's like,
unless you're allergic to them that I
understand,
but if it's like a,
like a nurture thing,
like you don't like animals that like
you or need you.
I'm I like my cat because I can push it
away and never cries.
I can leave food that's in a weekend.
That's a personality trait.
Like I love dogs.
What?
Somebody one time explain to me what a
dog is and they were talking.
I read this article about how dogs are
evolved to be really friendly and that's
how they manipulate the cosmos cosmos.
when I read that I went.
I was like,
maybe I Don't like my dog as much as I
used to.
I used to really like be like my dogs,
like a human.
I talked to them now I'm like,
yeah,
you're a dog here.
Manipulating me.
Know the circumstances.
Why I lost a little of my affection.
I love dogs.
I love them and I'll never not have
dogs.
My wife's allergic dogs.
I'm like,
tough shit.
Dog will have dogs,
but she takes medication shot.
She just doesn't like hug them as long
as she doesn't hug them.
It's fine.
It's not severe really.
Yeah.
But if she hugs him,
she's gets red marks on her arms.
It's very common.
But some people,
man,
like I'm Gary Valentine,
a buddy of mine,
you know gary comic,
he couldn't come over my house because I
have cats.
I have cats and dogs.
Dang dog.
I love animals.
I do too,
but not cat.
I'm allergic to them.
Never had a cap.
Gary couldn't even walk in the house.
He was his voice with his,
uh,
his,
his pipe start shrinking up.
Couldn't breathe.
He would make them whIstle if I,
if I came with the house,
can't touch my face.
My eyes swollen.
Shut.
Wow.
Allergic.
I'm allergic to nothing.
How about think about that.
What a weird response that is.
Normal shit for other people.
Like a bag of peanuts given to some
people and it's death.
Well,
well,
how about I was eating a lot of Brazil
nuts and then for whatever reason,
but the my mouth.
No.
Well yeah.
No,
not me.
Not me.
Get this.
The inside of my mouth would swell up to
the point where I was like,
why?
Why is he inside of mouth?
Literally I was like,
whoa,
whoa.
And it got worse and worse,
and then I was like,
what the hell is going on?
So my mother comes over and she goes,
those are Brazil nuts.
I go,
yeah.
She goes,
do you know if I eat one,
I would die.
And I went,
what do you mean?
She goes,
I can't even eat.
I said,
no,
she,
she ate half a Brazil nut that was in a
salad long time ago and she had to be
rushed to the hospital.
Why didn't this bitch tell you?
Right.
So what does that really mean?
I'm clearly alerted to Brazil nuts and I
was the wolfing down.
I mean wolfing down at least partially.
You probably don't have it as bad as
her,
but.
But when you lack,
I guess an enzyme for certain
nuts or whatever you.
Brazil nuts are high in zinc.
I have you.
Have you ever had your bLood tested for
what you're allergic to?
I want to do my genome.
I did a whole diet where they test your
blood type to see what your lieutenants
that I'm allergic to egg yolk and that's
really it.
Yeah,
nuts.
That's crazy,
bruh,
bro.
Brazil nuts actually can increase your
testosterone.
That's why I was eating them.
My trainer told me to take them in my
shake.
Really,
mass amount of them are lIke super
fucking healthy for you.
It says a salinium apparently.
Also it helps lower your ldl or bad
cholesterol,
reduces the Incidence of blood clots in
heart disease.
If I eat a shitload of brazilian nuts or
they need a lot of nuts,
brendan tested positive for Brazil.
Says here they actually caution limiting
yourself to no more than two Brazil nuts
per day because they are so loaded and
concentrated with millennium that you
don't want to overdose.
Copper and selenium are very important
minerals,
but with minerals like balance is really
key because you've got to be real
careful with like overdosing and certain
minerals.
There was cross a brazilian nuts.
I'll take this into account from dose to
dose daily.
They were selling these mega vitamins,
these,
uh,
these kind of talking about how they
were selling vitamin d tablets,
gel caps,
and it was 3000 over 3000 milligrams and
the guy said to get,
you'd have to eat 1500 almonds to get
that much vitamin e.
It's too much.
It's just too much.
You got a lot of vitamins,
you gotta you gotta.
Be careful.
You can't be an idiot.
Yeah,
that's pretty basic,
but it's easy to be an idiot.
Yeah.
It's easy to be an idiot,
you know.
That's what's really weird about this
supplement.
The supplement business like uh,
it's,
it's very tricky.
Like what effects certain people doesn't
affect other people.
Like with alpha brain for instance,
when we first put alpha brain now we had
slightly different ingredients because
some people had an adverse reaction.
They would get like a headache when they
would take.
It wasn't a dangerous thing,
but it was enough for like,
hm,
this is,
we got to back this down a little bit.
And so you,
you got to be careful with like certain
reactions that some people have.
You know like you with cats like you
with peanuts,
like that's the thing when it comes to
vaccinations,
like everybody talks about vaccinations,
like you're either in the camp of you
believe that vaccinations are evil and
they cause autism or you're in the camp
that those people are idiots and they're
dangerous and then these anti vaccine
people are really making all these
diseases like measles show up in New
York city again,
but the reality is that the truth lies
somewhere in the middle because yes,
vaccines are super important.
They're the reason why we don't have a
lot of infectious diseases that wrecked
havoc and there's science behind them
and it's fascinating.
The human beings have figured out how to
create these things that have fight off
diseases,
but some people are going to have
adverse reactions to everYthing.
Yep.
That's the reality of medication.
That's the reality of foods.
That's the reality to environment.
There's some people that can't small.
You're right,
you're right on with the masses,
but you're.
But you're dealing with 300 million
people for sure,
but when you're trying to get people,
but what I'm saying is when you have
those small amount of people,
if you have 300 million people and all
of them get vaccinated,
you're going to have 100 people,
a thousand people.
You can have all These examples of
things that went wrong and people look
at that and go,
well look,
there's so many people where things are
going wrong,
but what you're not thinking about is
the just sheer numbers of people that
kept from being diseased,
sheer numbers of people that we.
How we contain polio.
We contain anything.
Smallpox probably killed $500,
million people throughout history,
unbelievable.
And we squashed it out through
vaccination.
All put so many children in on iron
lungs and in wheelchairs,
and not only that,
they did it in our grandparents'
lifetime.
Know incredible,
incredible discoveries have been made by
science,
but it doesn't mean that some people
have adverse reactions.
Some people are going to eat peanuts and
they shouldn't.
They're going to die.
It's going to happen every year,
every year,
more than a thousand people die from
aspirin.
They take aspirin.
When you take supplements,
make sure you look into the data because
a lot of this stuff is not regulated,
so if you're going to take massive doses
of whatever it might be,
make sure you take a look at the data.
Take a look at the double blind studies,
see if it bears out well.
not only that,
it's also when you get,
when you get a supplement,
like say if you're running a supplement
company and you're buying vitamin b 12,
okay,
yeah,
you got to fucking task the vitamin b
12.
You get from the source,
whatever it is,
vitamin d,
whatever you're you're getting.
You have to test it.
You have to test it independently
because with alpha brain we've had to
make sure we had in the past we had
problems with manufacturers having like
bad mixtures like when you,
so calcium from bone meal has a great
deal of lead in it or some.
Something like that.
Think is What is crazy amounts of lead
in bone meal for whatever reason.
I can't remember if that's the exact
thing,
but it was,
it was like a metal,
it was a case,
a lawsuit,
and the vitamin company has brought up
on charges because the source of where
they were getting their calcium was very
heavy in.
Uh,
I believe it was lead metal.
Yeah.
So you got to know where it's sourced
from and you've got to know what your
body's life.
It's so hard to tell what the fuck's
going on your body.
I told you I was having that problem
with a.
I had arsenic in my blood.
It turned out it was from sardines.
Hey,
you're spending a shitload of every.
Every science I've had,
like I've talked to about podcasts and
stuff,
says they always come down to one thing.
None of them say meat's bad for you.
Can I take,
take them off?
Take.
I'd take four.
Yeah.
I'm going to get you some of the shrimp
tech through texts and fascinating shit.
Shroom tech sport.
Yeah.
It's all quarter steps.
Mushroom.
It's all a oxygen utilization.
I'll show you all the data behind it and
send it to you.
It was all a developed for the chinese
olympic team.
Really?
Yeah.
Fascinating stuff.
They found it in high altitude.
Hurting populations is animals that
would eat these,
uh,
these mushrooms would be more active.
And so the people started it and then
they started
cultivating it.
You started using from hearing you guys
talk.
It sounds like it should hire you as my
nutritionist.
I told you about this lady.
I have a good nutritionist.
A no,
joe.
No.
I know this story.
I was recommended to this late.
I'm not going to say her name or where
she was recommended this lady.
She goes,
yeah,
so this is what we do.
And she goes,
what are you looking to do?
I go,
I love,
I love to eat clean.
I feel goody and clean looking to lose
weight,
you know,
I want to stay the same way.
Just like eat healthy.
Perfect.
Ideal.
I deal with a lot of high level
athletes.
I got you.
I'm not making this shit up.
I showed brian this bitch gave me chili
cheese fries for breakfast,
chili cheese,
fries,
and rice was for my breakfast.
I took a picture of it,
emailed her.
I said,
I think,
I think my order got messed up because
you said you got to pick up your meals.
Right?
Right.
I think the order got messed up.
There's cheese and chili all over some
fries for my breakfast.
She goes,
you have a busy day of training.
You're going to need the calories.
Yeah.
She lasted for a week on brian.
Why don't you keep it for.
What about the meeting?
What was that meeting like?
I can watch all the meal.
Eat cheese fries,
chili cheese fries and crazy mail in the
mail.
My chili cheese fries better be fresh.
I want him in the mail.
They don't put them in the mail.
They delivered earlier in meals.
Delivered.
Unfair.
No,
I use a private company,
a small company.
So the woman who runs,
she runs it.
She was um,
she had a job as a um,
I forgot what it was,
but she,
she got fired or what have you.
And she starts her own food business.
WeLl,
yeah,
I got chili,
cheese,
fries.
I fired her.
And then,
um,
it,
it didn't go.
We didn't mix right from the start,
right when I was in a rush,
right?
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm here to pick up my meals,
blah,
blah.
She's like,
well,
can we just sit down for a while?
I'm like,
sure.
So she's like,
well,
you gotta sign this contract.
I'm going over it.
It's like,
oh,
hi brendan schaub for the next 30 slash
77 days will not eat junk food.
I'm like,
yeah,
whatever.
I will not drink soda.
I don't drink soda.
Third one down will not drink coffee.
I will skip that one.
Keep going.
Well,
not well,
not cool.
And she's looking at it,
going through the page.
She goes,
okay,
we're good.
Oh,
you missed one right here.
And I go,
yeah,
you're talking about the coffee one.
She goes,
yeah,
yo,
that ain't happening.
She goes,
skews mega.
I mean,
we can get into this if you want,
but there's clinical studies that show
coffee,
helps out with workouts and I mean it's
not bad for you if you do it in
moderation.
She goes,
well then I don't know.
I go,
well,
I'll tell you right now.
It's not going to work out.
I'll walk ouT right now.
She goes,
all right,
I'll make one exception and then just
right then I was like,
god,
this is not going good.
Yeah,
I don't work with her anymore.
Long story short,
she got fired.
Chili cheese fries should have fired
her.
That shit's ridiculous.
You should be eating fruit and
vegetables,
not chili fries.
Chili cheese fries with rice.
And she said the calories.
Oh my god,
she's so retarded.
This is pre workout.
Did she ever
worked out hard a day in her life?
Do you know what kinda throw up and shit
would come out of your body if you eat
chili cheese,
fries and that did like a strength and
conditioning workout.
Did box jumps and kettle bells and
battle ropes.
Chili running through your bowels.
You ready for this?
I,
I'm going to launch at the bell.
The only heavy weighting.
Who's on a diet like this?
It's called the alpha diet.
I don't eat breakfast.
I do bulletproof coffee and the mct oil
and I hit the ground running.
Well,
that is about don't you juice in the
morning?
Vegetable juice?
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh well that's something too and you'd
be amazed at how much butter and mct oil
you're dealing.
The reason why this bulletproof blend
works is because you have the healthy
fats connected to the caffeine.
It's a slow burn of the caffeine,
but you can't get over the actual
calories.
I mean someone should take one of these
things and find out how much like a
thermos of this bitch is calorically
with that much butter and that much mct
oil.
I bet it's quite a bit.
Oh yeah.
Eating a funk on hunk of butter takes a
while for your body to digest those
fats,
but it's.
I'm it though.
You could burn.
It's a great way to work out,
like to drink that stuff in the morning
because you feel full,
you have energy and yet you still get a
good workout and drinking.
What about eating a sugar source before
you work out?
like a,
like what would it be good.
Like they say nothing's better than
fruits.
So not pancakes or.
No,
no,
no.
That's terrible for you.
Pick some chili cheese fries.
If you're doing endurance sports.
Gluten is a tricky thing,
man,
because if you have a bad reaction to
gluten,
um,
you're,
you're going to have all sorts of issues
and even if you don't have a bad
reaction to gluten,
the studies are showing pretty clearly
that it causes inflammation and it may
be fine,
but with a lot of people,
you get this bloated appearance.
Like I've seen people go from wheat to
no wheat and then they're,
the face shrinks in their body,
looks different.
It's like your body's inflamed and it's
a lot of weird calories.
It's calories where your body's breaking
down glue,
you know?
I mean taste great.
I mean,
I love lasagna,
I love pasta,
I love delicious bread.
Don't.
It's great.
You go to a restaurant,
italian restaurant,
they bring over that pregnant,
smell it and yes,
I'll put some butter on that and me and
brian like a nice cheese plate,
little cheese plates,
these plates.
Nice.
It is.
The problem is gluten is just not a
smart choice.
If you thinking about what you're going
to put in your body,
why fuck around with that?
You could have lettuce and you can have
all sorts of delicious greens and you
could have fresh meats.
You're going to have a good.
Your body's going to get good nutrients,
can have What it needs when you're
having gluten or pasta or anything like
that.
You're just giving it a nice delicious
taste,
and if that's where you're cool with,
that's cool.
You know you're just out on a date,
one to have a delicious meal,
but if you want performance food for
your body,
you really shouldn't fuck with anything
that's complicated.
Exactly.
Sweet potato,
chicken breasts,
sweet potatoes and yams.
Fish.
You know,
if you can get some game,
get some deer.
buffalo.
Yeah.
You know what else
is good?
Lamb.
Ryan.
What'd?
What'd you guys hunt?
Deer.
Good,
good.
So rich in nutrients and vitamins ever
had it.
So low in cholesterol roasted.
I'll make a roast steak.
A 12 ounce elk stake has less
cholesterol than a 12 ounce chicken
breast to shit on that sticker.
There's nothing better than elk.
So good for you too.
It tastes so good.
It's like almost got a sweet taste to
it.
It's a dark red meat.
Oh,
elk tenderloin grill.
It's so stupid.
I was eating every meal,
every meet including mountain lion,
and he goes,
ah,
yeah.
He said,
if I had the one meeting every day,
it'd be out.
Yeah.
A lot of people think that giant animal
never had elk.
You should be hunter.
You'd love it.
Hate.
I hate.
I sent a picture of the deer and we
could use bone marrow.
I'd be telling,
man,
we'd be down for that.
Oh yeah,
let's do it.
I said the three of us,
deer hunting to hone ranch would be down
for that.
I bet you would be down for naked and
afraid.
I'm doing this thing.
Doing his thing.
No,
no.
We're gonna wear.
I'm gonna wear extra clothes just
because I love it.
I think I would wreck shop on that show.
I think you do find until you got your
dick bit by a spider and then you cry.
There you go.
Because I'm telling you to own ranch,
hour and a half north of here.
We stay for a weekend.
We film it.
We go pig hunting with bows and arrows
to it.
I'm so down for two days though,
right?
Two days.
Saturday and sunday,
and then we say,
hey,
and then we spot on sunday.
I'll fill his spot,
spot each other lifting spot,
spa,
hot tub,
facials.
I got confused.
I was like,
he's a prima donna.
They'll be like,
what if he.
If he got the toughest one of the
toughest guys in the planet,
he misses a meal.
If he's a half hour late to him,
you know,
he's like this,
I'm lightheaded man.
I'm starving.
But you gotta think of what he's doing
with his body all day.
You can't even imagine.
I'm chilly.
I'm cold.
You guys.
Imagine how fucking much he works out.
I know you don't.
You don't take that into consideration.
No,
I don't.
Brian who I work out all the time once a
week,
he might get in a workout once a week
and he probably instagrams that to just
work out moderately.
You might work out once a week.
You might go a month.
He's the guy on was the longest day.
How many days have you gone?
The longest without anyone at work.
Every single day.
The fuck away from that question.
I'll come to your house and find you not
working out.
How about this box?
Twice a week,
but I work out too.
I don't work out.
I don't ever work out everyday.
Nobody works out every day.
You need days off.
I take sunday off.
Oh,
well,
almost now.
It's almost used to be.
I workout everyday.
I'll tell you what though.
Brian's footwork is impressive.
It's impressive.
When I saw pres.
Thank you buddy is a dancer.
I'm going to teach them different moves.
Move his feet around it.
He's got an aldi.
Tony's a good teacher,
man.
Trying to try to move around that guy.
My god the best.
Oh,
by the way,
I am when I'm.
By the way,
and by the way again,
I am definitely not.
As you get more tired boxing,
just try to just try to move around and
you're exhausted.
Focus right now.
Can we?
Can you pull in your cock?
Kelsey's tight ass peter.
Pan green jeans on peace and it's peace.
It's just bulging out.
What are you doing?
I'm an american.
Rather than your crocodile?
No,
but whenever I'm around brendan,
a little extra blood flows in.
Well,
you know what it is.
It's that same thing that causes men
chimps to have bigger balls.
It's like you're around a an alpha male,
and he's like,
well,
I'm trying to compete and your dick is
like,
we better get bigger for sure.
Get your dick out of my face.
Yeah.
That's not the way to compete for sure.
It very.
Obviously you're mixing it up.
You get confused.
They'll get these chimps.
Paul's looking at that.
Yeah.
That's it.
The muscles on that chance.
Jesus christ.
Good luck with that.
No,
it's cancer or brutality,
but totally different tendonous
structure.
Everything's bigger and thicker.
Everything's ridiculous.
God,
that thing weighs 150 pounds and they
can throw itself through the air with
its arms.
Let's imagine that they grab a branch
and just throw themselves through the
air.
It's that other one like it's velcro and
just hang and fucking.
They could be a thousand feet off the
ground hanging from a branch.
Do you,
joe?
Do you think you could tear it up on
naked and afraid?
Me and brian,
you wouldn't do well.
No one days.
Nope.
First of all,
the stupidity of it all would insult me
as a human being so dumb that I was
willing to be on a show that was
exploiting me to the point of making me
naked.
Go through the fucking jungle.
I'd be like,
after one day I'd be like,
oh my god,
I'm an asshole.
I am such an that.
This is who I am.
I'm not spiderman.
I'm not fucking herschel walker talker
too.
He'd be like,
this pillow was my with dirt on my balls
and I'm like,
this is so stupid.
I'm sleeping on dirt.
There's spiders everywhere.
I just like the challenge.
I'm not outdoors.
Guy had hunting gear like joe and I did
with gear with tense.
That's a bitch.
That sounds super boring.
It wasn't boring at all.
It was very exciting.
Brian in Montana,
I was scary.
That was fun.
It was really fun.
We went rafting 40 miles down the
Missouri river place where there's
nobody.
I mean we saw five people in five days.
I'm down to kill animals with a bow gun
does nothing for me.
Just super boring guns is a great way to
do it because you definitely kill them
and you also can get them at a large
distance so you can get many more shots.
Like getting up on some animals is super
problematic.
Problematic with a bone arrow,
like what we did kind of hunting.
We did,
yeah.
They started a lot too.
They also,
you know,
they.
They had been doing.
they did okay and did pretty well.
There's a lot more buffalo back then
they didn't have the long range rifle
capabilities of wait,
so they got in the water.
A lot of times they went to,
they,
they crossed the river and then they we
to do that.
That could
be the three of us.
We wait until they get in the water.
We start just bam,
bam,
bam.
Whenever I have a 90 pound draw,
it shoots a 475 green arrow,
which is pretty heavy.
Three hundred and two feet per second.
It blows through everything.
It'll blow through a buffalo and elk
there.
Everything.
Boom,
right through bone.
Everything.
Boom.
It's gone right?
It goes through trees.
I shoot it.
If I,
if I missed the target and it hit like
it hit the,
um,
I had the target set up on this a fence
post.
It blew right through the fence post,
like a big hey by four of would blew
right through and out the other side,
a two by four.
Think about what it would do to a body.
Wow.
Yeah.
And so one of those,
you might as well have a gun,
but you're going to have to be close
enough to hit it and shooting anything
20 yards away,
it's tough.
Forty yards away is really tough.
Like the difference between when I shoot
a target that's 20 yards away and 40
yards away,
like the amount of movement that you
could do before you release the arrow,
a 20,
you got a little bit of wiggle room and
then you can release it,
but you get to 40 and it's so minute
because you're looking at something
that's not magnified your site and
you're looking at target that's so small
because it's so far away and you just
keeping that motherfucker right there
and then letting it go.
Don't you find that more exciting than
having this done?
That basically does it all itself.
It's like a video games.
Definitely more exciting.
Animal comes walking through your
fricking.
Here's the problem with that logic
though.
Here's a problem with that logic.
That poor animal will definitely get
killed.
If you have a rifle with a scope.
If you have a rifle,
a scope,
you're looking at that animal from 200
yards away.
That's a dead animal.
Boom.
You're blowing a hole through that thing
clean.
If that deer is sitting there,
it's all in you not fucking up or your
your gear being off.
You could I.
I fucked up in Wisconsin.
I dropped my rifle.
I fell on a hill and my rifle scope.
Then when they installed the scope,
changed the scope.
When we got to Wisconsin and the guY
when he put the scope on,
didn't have it tight and when we fail,
it was like you could lose it where you
can move it with your fingers and it
caused an animal.
Get wounded you.
You don't want that and you have a way
more of a chance of that with a bow and
arrow way hard to shoot an animal with a
rifle.
Shooting an animal with a bow and arrow
is really good.
All this technology now that's hard.
When I saw the video of you,
the three of you just chilling like this
one sleeping bag,
telling jokes and then this little like
reindeer came prancing around and
caribou.
They live in Alaska.
You had like a bazooka and it came a
bazooka.
No,
it wasn't a.
It was a canon light.
We had a helicopter gunshIp greater than
me while you eat me,
dude,
what are you talking about?
You're just getting something that's
tortured all its life and then shoved
into a fucking vice and they put a
piston.
I'm not against it.
I'm just saying it doesn't seem very
exciting.
It's very exciting when that animal
comes out of the woods and it's looking
around.
When you get an animal in your sites,
first of all,
you've been tracking it for three days,
four days and you haven't seen and it's
a wild animal.
I'm just saying if you were it with,
with,
with bows and arrows,
technology,
it'd be a lot cooler.
Well,
here's the thing.
In Montana where we were,
if you were bow hunting,
you're fucked.
You're not going to get it close enough.
Shot.
The closest shot I got was 200 yards.
Those the only shot that I got,
I got one deer shot it at 200 yards.
There's a long way.
The you can't even see that far with a
bow and arrow site.
I mean the idea that you're going to
hold that dear and it's gonna look so
small when you're looking at it with not
even harder.
It's not.
I mean,
I don't think anybody's ever done it.
I mean maybe a few people have done it,
but you have to be like expert archers
to shoot a deer at 210 to 20 yards.
But with a rifle that's,
that's common.
Super common.
Yeah.
You know,
you line it up,
it's a magnifying rifle,
you see the deer really clearly.
You locked the cross on his heart and
boom,
it's over.
I think hundred would be a lot more
cooler if if you were hunting like
something that could sneak up on you and
kill you,
it'd be a lot cooler.
The problem like that,
like dear.
Oh no,
I missed it goes prance and away.
You know what I'm saying?
Like who cares?
So it would be cooler if Your life was
in danger.
That deere hat,
like salim was like waterways,
water buffalo when you,
when you should have water buffalo.
A lot of timeS they disappear into the
tall grass and you must go into that.
Tallgrass and,
and finish them off.
Now the video of cameron hanes shooting
a water bugs.
He's waiting for you.
My friend cameron hanes,
who uh,
is the guy who got me hooked up with
hoyt and he's the guy who got me the 90
pound bow is the same boat that he
shoots.
So I shot it at my house and it's so
accurate.
I like,
I gotta get one of these things.
It's incredibLe.
It's so accurate.
It makes me more confident to shoot
because I know that if it hits something
it's because it's got sites that are
really,
really.
Yes,
and it's just.
So look at this.
He,
he snuck up on this 2000 pound water
buffalo in Australia.
They are dangerous.
Fuck yeah they are.
We'll try running first of all runs
faster than you and it weighs 2000
pounds.
That's crazy.
So it only sees movement.
So You see how he's not moving.
The reason why he's not moving is
because it's stopped because it's sense
movement.
So then when it goes back to eating,
he starts creeping in.
This whole process is taking him along
to this guy.
This guy I'm going hunting with shape
two.
he's in very good shape.
He does 20 eIght chin ups.
That's one of the reasons why he does
it.
So you could pull back this monster bow
because that beau is most human beings.
I mean you can pull it back.
Brian can't.
I'm so I'll do 28.
So eight pounds.
So how did he get this?
So this is a friend of his.
Behind him is filming this.
See,
obviously there's a guy who was holding
the camera,
so he's is a long,
slow process.
You don't have to speed it up,
leave it alone.
Jamie,
this was a long,
slow process where he has to wait for
this animal to give him a broadside shot
and when the animal's facing him,
he can't move at all.
This guy doesn't hunt with rifles.
All you hunt with bows and arrows.
I liked this 60 pound ball and it was
really hard.
You're such a bitch going to shoot this
thing at the day and it takes a long
time bro,
because if you fuck up the thing knows
you're there and it's running at you.
Essentially it can't jump behind.
The chair goes,
here it goes,
so now the thing is going to give him a
broadside shot.
It's close enough.
He's down to about 30 yards with a shot.
With an animal like this,
you want to ensure that you shoot that
thing through the fucking heart standing
faced the wrong way.
It has to go sideways totally because
right now it's quartering away,
so you're only going to hit the shoulder
and it might not hit a vital organ.
So then you've got an angry buffalo with
a stick in his arm and then it's running
at you and it weighs 2000 pounds and it
runs 40 miles an hour.
Good luck.
I'm for sure.
Hi mohan.
Those trees.
But look,
this thing is waiting and so he doesn't
move man,
because it's looking at it.
Look at this dude.
So this is a long fucking stock man.
This is like a 20 minute stock or he's
standing there with his 90 pound fucking
bones man and he's not moving left.
So noW it goes back to eating.
It's decided that he's not.
He's nothing to be ashamed or to be
concerned with.
Ashamed of.
And I saved up.
So now look,
now he sees it and he pulls it back.
Good.
I think runs off.
It's got to fucking grow through.
It goes through.
It's the side of its arm and right into
its heart.
That's Why there's so much blood pouring
out of it.
That's why he hit it there.
Yeah.
Well those animals,
you have to.
You have to know the anatomy of each
individual animal because animals have
their vitals in different areas.
So it's got.
It's got an arrow.
It's heart right now.
Yeah.
So it's going to sit there for a couple
seconds then realize it's done that
shit.
Unlike that.
There it is.
It's going to figure it out any second
now it just drops.
I mean when you're dealing with an
animal that's that big.
Any other animal like a north american
animal would be dead.
A bear would be dead.
A deer would be dead.
Anything that's.
But this is just an enormous gigantic
animal.
Kidding me right now.
Look at this.
Yeah,
and it sort of takes awhile.
It's just sort of bleed out and it
wanders off and collapses.
He said he ate it and wayne,
he put one piece in his mouth and he
chewed it for half an hour before he
could swallow it.
That's some,
that's some dense muscle.
Not only that,
when they were there,
they didn't bring any food.
they brought just enough snacks to get
them through like a day and they didn't
bring any water,
so they had a boil.
All This water and the water all had
buffalo piss in it.
So every drank,
every sip of water they drank was
buffalo pissed.
There's the thing fell.
It's done.
wait,
now this was in um,
in Australia.
Yeah.
Australia.
I didn't know water buffaloes were in
Well,
they're not native.
Oh,
okay.
This is what happened.
One of the reasons why they encourage
people to go over there and shoot them
there.
A non native invasive species,
theY brought him over there,
but they don't have any natural
predators.
There's some things that can eat them,
like when they're babies,
like a crocodile I the size of that
thing,
man.
Jesus fucking christ.
Um,
some things can eat them when theY're
babies.
Yeah.
Crocodiles mosTly.
he's jacked.
He's in shape.
yeah.
He's in very good shape.
But like I said,
he all this shit
just stick.
Trained for hunting.
Yep.
This guy,
um,
he runs ultra marathons,
so living hunt down.
He's a,
he's got a television show and he's
sponsored by a bunch of different
companies like under armor.
He's a famous bonner,
but this guy like he,
he does ultra marathons.
He ran a 100 mile marathon beast.
He's an animal.
He's just,
that's what he does and he just does it
all.
Bow and arrow style.
That's my.
That's the shop.
After you retire,
you're going to need an outlet for all
this savage aggression you got inside
your body.
So I'll tell you what,
I'm not doing what?
Waiting six hours and shooting a water
buffalo.
Say you're not man,
not iron man.
You like to hang out with you guys.
I'll drink beers and stuff.
You'll do a lot of jujitsu.
I feel like when you retire.
Retire for fighting.
Yeah.
Do you have any?
I'm going to do the world's actually in
may.
Are you really an ag?
Not geeky.
Whoa.
Wow.
You training with the gate?
Do you feel like that?
Do you feel like it helps you in any
way?
Would I do?
because if I have a 250 pound black
built on top of me and I can escape his
site controller or I can control them
when you take off the tee and these guys
are trying to punch me.
Man,
it's,
it's easy for me really.
That's interesting.
So,
um,
it's uh,
easier to defend because when you're
defending with the ge you're more,
you hAve to be more technical with the
gif.
So much to worry about.
I have to worry about color chokes.
The guy can grab me and control me
through my age,
you know what I'm saying?
So you feel like it's cross training?
Yes.
It takes away my explosiveness and my
athleticism and it forces me to use
technique.
I found that with defense for sure.
I get caught in a lot of arm bars with
the key that I would have never got
crushed.
But also my in my defense goes through
the roof.
Really?
Yeah.
So you play a different game when you
start doing that,
you just become much more technical and
much more aware of where the positions
are.
Yeah.
How flexible are you,
man?
Uh,
in cerTain areas like my hamstrings are
really tight,
but pretty flexible.
Yeah.
Do you have a.
Well,
I shouldn't ask you this because someone
fight.
You might try to exploit it.
what do you work your guard?
Yeah,
some guys are like,
fuck it,
I ain't going to be on my back.
That's stupid.
No,
listen,
when,
when I get taken down a little bit and
taken down twice in the octagon.
But um,
I do not care.
Like if hunt was the whole game plan,
if he trained all this wrestling still
have a tough time taking me down.
But if you trained all this wrestling
and decided to put me on my back,
cool,
let's do it.
I'm all game for that.
I don't panic down.
I'm very comfortable down there.
I spent because you gotta remember my
daycare was shane carlin on top of me.
I wasn't,
I wasn't getting a lot of take downs.
I was on my back all the time.
That's a crazy way to start your
training in mma.
It was horrible.
Horrible mess.
So credit is it like everyday just beat
me up.
Trevor whitman seems like a crazy dude,
man.
He's A good dude.
I mean like a very good dude.
Good guy.
I haven't been there in years.
A maniac like he had shane car when I'm
like why they wanted to have shankar
wind sport spar with gsp and gsp was
like,
what?
Yeah,
why
would I,
why?
Why would I spar him?
Like what are you talking about?
You and I think like trevor's a genius
when comes straight and stuff like that.
But I think back on it and there's this
thing where I felt like I had to prove
day everyone I could hang with shane
carlin and no matter when we were
sparring,
that's how my footwork got so good
because I'm used to this giant water
buffalo mad water buffalo chasing me
around the octagon.
So I was trying to get out of the way
because he landed right hand.
It was a short and he was not good man.
Yeah,
that's trouble.
He hits so hard.
He's got.
So I got used to that right.
And I'm moving nonstop.
And then when the bell go dinging with
30 seconds left,
literally no matter what we're doing,
me and shane would stop walk to the
middle of the cage and just rock 'em
sock 'em robots.
I did that for three years.
And then finally a part of me was like a
how about no.
And I shot a double bag on them and
we've never done that again.
Yeah.
But I think back on my training,
I'm like,
god,
that was stupid.
Even taking them down.
I mean,
he's so strong.
He's a big guY.
This guy ever is a big fucking guy,
man.
Strong.
A lot stronger than you and your strong
shane is 100 percent stronger than me.
NoT even close.
he's ridiculously strong.
bone structure is just.
He's bigger than me.
He's bigger than lesnar.
Legs are thick,
thick ass.
Huge shoulders.
His hands,
man,
before they did the,
they redid the ufc glove to fit over his
hands.
Shane's.
The reason why they changed the glove.
Shane had a five xl gloves.
You have to cut the glove just to get
over to his hands are so ridiculous when
you shake them.
It's like holding onto a hand.
So what was frustrating to me is,
you know,
I've always been in love with jujitsu.
I would spend,
shane would get injured or you'd have to
work at a regular job and I was just
trained full time and I would think I
was being so good at jujitsu and shane
would come in off a nine to five shift
walk in.
But jujitsu hunt,
let's do it.
I'm like,
I'm going roll this big dude.
you just shut.
Shut it all down.
When I was training at a mall,
he came by and uh,
and,
and trained one day and uh,
I didn't get to roll with them,
but uh,
I watched people roll with them and it
was,
it was like a child playing with his
daddy.
Bear with me just like rolling over.
And I go with big guys,
all the big guys all the time,
but none like shane when he doesn't even
look real.
when he walked in the door,
if I didn't know him,
I was like,
what's up shane?
But if I didn't know him,
I would say to look at this
motherfucker.
He's got legs grown out of his
shoulders.
This is how it happened.
I was like,
oh,
I want to be a fighter.
I knew neymar cart.
I looked him up online,
found out.
Whereas cademy was in aurora,
my hometown.
I show up there.
Nate's a great guy,
right?
He's like,
yeah man,
well we Can do.
We can do this.
We'll figure it out.
Come tomorrow.
There's another big guy.
He just,
he only has like one fight.
He just started fighting and he played
football too.
Like,
oh cool.
I show up.
It's sparring,
right?
I show up and in blockchain current at
the time is 315 lbs.
Fighting the wec just jacked,
looked like a silver back gorilla that
just found the weight room and does
nothing else.
Just remember when he was really that
big.
There's a picture of him that doesn't
even look real.
It's insane.
And nicos nicos,
oh hey,
here's the guy wanted to do is introduce
you to in a.
Since then me and shane and we just
stood toe to toe.
Neither one of us knew what we were
doing,
blasting each other and you rolled with
that mean you had the biggest and the
baddest as a training partner forever.
The best man was.
He was like a little brother.
I couldn't afford private training with
trevor whitman and chain blue to me.
So much.
He paid for my training with trevor.
For a guy like shane having a guy like
you around invaluable,
you know,
trying to find a giant picture of me and
him in emilia.
I think one or two fights at the time
had zero.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
And he was a really good wrestler as
well.
And his,
his issue reallY.
He had a lot of issues from football
health,
brought a always neck injuries and back
injuries.
He had a lot of um,
a lot of problems with his back man.
You know,
the body's just not designed to have 300
pound dudes running out.
You full clips as well.
It's also not designed to be 300 pounds
and shredded muscle.
It's just not.
That's true to anyone.
I know anyone,
and I know a lot of athletes like high
level athletes,
anyone who's that big,
that lean and whether natural,
not they're always hurt,
they're always heard or they always,
they're always sick for whatever reason.
They just have bad immune systems or
they're fighting.
So yeah,
that's the most ridicuLous thing I've
ever seen him.
That's when he was at his biggest
saving.
You'd find that picture.
Jamie looks like,
hey,
uh,
just a bodybuilder.
So I googled shane carwyn huge bro.
I sparring sparring days.
I used to sit in my car outside the gym
and I was so nervous,
man,
like,
dang,
I don't want to do this.
Look at that picture.
Look at him.
Get the fuck outta here.
First of all,
does not look like a gaY porn picture.
Pull out,
pull out his hairless car and stuff,
and write in your button all shaved
down.
ThIs is no way.
That guy's not going to put such a
monster.
It doesn't even look real.
That looks photoshop,
he not gabriel.
Gonzaga was just just her.
Here's one thing I noticed about him is
he's got super long arms,
a little news flash when he fought frank
mir,
he might've hit myths,
I don't know,
three times.
I really,
really just.
Yeah,
he was hurt.
What was wrong with him?
Uh,
his back is going to prom so he couldn't
train a lot.
That's why I went after him so quick.
Maybe got that under hook,
got that under hook and those upper cuts
won't drop them in.
And he was hitting him with left to
right.
Yeah.
Left.
Get that under hook.
Yeah.
And he's known for his right hand and
meanwhile he starts to him with the
left.
He was just such a gorilla.
The poor health problems.
Late man.
Yeah.
But it's also just the football,
all that football.
I mean he had a lot of injuries from
wrestling.
He's just a rugged dude.
You make a real good point though about
guys there are that big because
everyone.
I know everyone.
I'm telling you,
one of my best friends,
he was in the nfl.
Not anymore.
A six,
seven,
two 65.
Shredded.
Right.
He's just always been that way.
Never been on drugs,
nothing always hurt,
man.
He had to retire because he was always
hurt.
Had surgeries that kind of weight on
your body and they're alwayS sick.
They're like shane was always sick.
His immune sYstem was shit,
man.
Shane also worked.
That's a hard fucking propagation of
time job and be a professional mma
fighter fighting for titles,
fighting,
check,
check has contended.
Shane and I first started.
He worked you not.
We both worked nine to five jobs at the
time when we very first started,
nine to five jobs.
We'd both get off.
We'd go drive straight to the gym.
He would drive an hour.
I'd drive like 15 minutes.
You drive an hour to the gym and we
would be at the gym from six to 10:30
at night.
We'd do four classes back to back,
back.
Hey,
we should do a podcast like this.
Like afTer ufc.
Yes,
we should do like one will commit to
like one a month.
It's three shit man.
Let's Do it.
This is for the.
I figured we could talk mma for days,
throwiNg crocodiles And fucking terror
birds,
joint fighter,
and the kid will do joint fighter and
the kid like,
this'll be one of our episodes.
Yeah,
whatever man we can do.
You know,
we could record it and both released
them simultaneously.
We do anything.
We do whatever we want and we don't,
but that would be really fun to break
down fights.
I'm fucking pumped about tim kennedy and
michael bisping.
This other thing with this.
The other thing with carla and what's
weird is there's the days of carwyn
lesnar who you just have these dudes who
are grill us cutting from 300 pounds of
[inaudible].
Sixty five [inaudible] not that way
anymore at the big boys are gone now.
You guys got like cain to 40 junior dos
santos to 40,
big brown to 40.
Everyone's kind of the more athletic.
I agree and I think that there's a point
of diminishing return,
right?
When you get too big,
your body just can't keep it up.
It's just like When you saw kane.
I'm just running all over brock,
like the pace that he put on brock.
First of all,
you're dealing with a brock that was
sick,
so it's hard to look at that like you
when now that we know that the dude had
that serious diverticulitis issue,
but it doesn't mean you turn away from
punches.
Go carry on.
That's very good point.
There's also the issue of trying to deal
with a guy who's been striking for a
long fucking time and you are
essentially anonymously,
right?
You knoW,
and you can't take the guy down if you
do take.
the guy did take it,
took,
came down,
it came,
pops right back up to his feet.
Now you have to deal with that pace.
Well that,
but also mentally for him,
he gets guys down,
they're screwed.
Exactly.
Came down,
can got double risk and popped up.
Yeah.
And you and lazlo was like,
damn.
You can see in his face like,
holy shit.
That's why when he fought shane,
I was like,
this fights over.
This fight's over.
And then they didn't stop at sec around
shane just kind of get.
Shane was dealing with some problems,
gases out.
Basically his body shut down on,
gets choked out.
I fought on the same night,
right?
Fought brock lesnar's best friend
training partner.
That Was the thing,
right lesnar carwyn training partners
find each other on spike the main card
on spike.
I'm not.
Chris touched her out and 50 seconds.
I'm like,
he's a big fat slob and he's 21 though.
Tough dude.
Twenty one second.
A nice guy,
man.
He was 20 in one though.
Yeah,
but I'm all excited.
I'm all excited.
I come running back.
I'm not touching that.
I come back.
I come back to the locker room and then
shane's turned to get ready.
He's getting ready.
I thought he was the fight one.
I was crunk right?
Because I want my fight.
I've never been so sad in my life when
shane lost that fight because we did
training camps together.
He's like a brother heavyweight
champion.
It didn't happen.
We're both crying,
right?
Both crying her eyes out in the locker
room.
Dana white comes in because everyone
leaves the room.
I'm all really sharp.
You can stay like,
thanks dana.
Shane,
shane's literally on the floor with ice
on his heart,
ice on his heart because his body's gone
crazy.
She's laying on the floor.
It looks like a giant gorilla.
And sweating,
sweating,
ice on his heart,
on his hands all over.
Right.
Dana makes everyone leave the room.
He give shane a check.
That was like,
what is it,
man?
I look.
I'm like,
oh shit.
Wow.
I popped up.
Fuck it man.
Let's do this.
It was a lot of money.
I stopped crying.
So did shane.
Wow.
The ice bags.
No,
that's real money.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well that was a crazy first round man.
If he pays himself and picked his shot's
better,
why would he though?
They should've stopped the fight.
He's been to break up the fight.
I've seen fights stop for a lot less
cable.
When you were out that to be stopped,
that was you and you were okay.
Like brock was.
Brock got back to his corner and he was
all right.
I mean he got hit with some big shots.
I agree,
but he defended.
You know what?
That's when I got a lot of respect for
brock.
After that fight,
I was like,
right,
he's legit.
He's legit.
Then I was like,
now sign me up.
He got rocked.
He got cut.
He had plenty of time to give up.
Plenty of time to give up.
That's when you were like,
I legit just didn't know how to deal
with canes hands.
Well came was just too much.
And also he was.
He.
He's operating in history.
His estimation at 40 percent.
What does that mean in the real world?
Only he knows,
buT he definitely had diverticulitis.
Then even if you have 100 percent,
I agree with you.
An a plus.
A plus brock.
Horrible matchup for.
But I think it would be a great fight
though.
Fun fight while it lasted,
but I don't think they really don't
think so.
I don't know why because.
Because.
Because candy canes a lot smarter,
has more tools.
His gas tank so much better.
I think after awhile it take its toll on
brock and he tko them.
Time after time.
Junior dos santos will never be the same
again.
I don't think so either.
No,
never ever be the same again.
Those two fights were fucking insane.
The corners should have threw in the
towel.
yeah,
well,
you know when,
when it ended too.
It's crazy because it ended from him
falling on his head.
He,
you know,
he got,
he got a,
he tried to do like a power,
good teen on,
on cain and cain ducked under and junior
was so tired and he'd taken such a
beating that he's holding onto this team
and he literally falls forward right
onto his head and like stuns himself.
Then they Stopped the fight,
but the beating that he took up until
that,
there was three st pete times were herb
dean was like moving close to stop the
fight and then juniors heart pulled
through.
It was insane.
Junior dos santos does not fucking give
up.
That's one.
He had as many opportunities to give up
as a human being ever gets in Life and
he will not give up.
It's tough.
right?
And I think about this,
it,
it's tough because if junior came five
years ago,
he's not dealing with,
he's the champ for a long time,
but because there's this group of guys
and it's about matchups.
Ufc is about matchups cain velasquez,
junior.
Dos santos junior will never beat them.
right.
He got that one lucky shot.
Other than that,
those guys fight 100 times.
Canes went in [inaudible] 99.
Usually he just,
he just.
However,
if junior fights verdugo,
travis brown,
he's probably gonna win.
It's just matchups man who is a better
match up for you for doom or,
or,
or um,
uh,
alice drove,
I mean,
that's random as hell.
But uh,
or who's,
it's just,
it's,
it's.
So you see a guy like allister that was
at a very high level and kickboxing came
over,
fought lesnar,
looked fantastic,
but then you see him in the big foot
fight post getting popped.
He got popped for testosterone.
You seem in the bigfoot fight.
and then you see him in the travis brown
fight.
How much do you think he's lost from not
having?
This is the thing though,
like he's destroying these guys,
right,
and then you don't want to be that guy
in the first two minutes fighting
alistair overeem.
It is a nightmare,
but he didn't fight that way against me
or against me or he was very controlled.
Thanks for that fight.
They mirror.
What the fuck are we doing?
What did you do?
All training camp.
What are we doing?
I don't think you did nothing.
What do you say?
Nothing.
He didn't throw a punch.
I don't think he could hit him.
I mean,
I think he was having a real problem.
Do something,
man.
I wonder what the game plan was.
I would love to hear it.
I bet.
I bet the game plan was figured out how
to tire him out and get them down to the
ground.
I bet that was probably the game plan.
Stay on the outside was be very
conservative.
Don't gas out.
And [inaudible] is also controlling on
the ground.
You know,
he wasn't afraid of going to the
controller the heck out of them,
which is pretty shocking,
you know,
ran frank's a hell of a grappler and
really good off his back.
People forget that.
Alister one,
the uh,
abu dhabi,
a european trials though alastair can
the nasty canteen.
Yeah.
He admitted vitara submitted veto with
geese submitted.
Mark hunt via camera.
Yeah,
that's right.
And a weird one too.
I told him if he needed,
I would open up a jujitsu school farm in
New Zealand.
So yeah.
So we had an idea what's going on on the
ground.
Well,
didn't you guys make some sort of a bet
like you would try to knock him out and
he would try to submit you wasn't there
something along those lines.
We need him.
We're talking smack on twitter and then
we got into this winner takes all and he
started clowning and how he's getting
knocked me out and stand up.
Fighter and the kid.
Come on,
stand on your big letters.
I was like,
what's wrong with your list?
Your leg to stand on your big lips and
knock you out.
I think kids.
Could you talk a lot?
That's probably.
I have big lips,
so it's confusing.
You have a good day.
I wouldn't say that like really big.
I met a lot of black.
I wouldn't describe you that way.
Like would describe brenden's shop.
Oh,
The lips.
Big lips.
Describe ms dot big brown.
Me and him got on it on twitter.
Trying to get his name and trying to get
his nickname change from hybrid to big
brown.
This guy starts with big brown,
big brown.
He's big brown.
He's just big and brown.
That's why everybody calls him big
brown.
Now he's walking with nationality.
What's your nationality?
My mom's full blooded english.
It's bullshit.
Born and raised in a patchy.
Born and raised in jewish,
german.
A little bit of talent.
French native american and jewish.
100 percent.
I don't care what anybody says.
You got some.
Do you ever do you genome test to see if
anybody's lying?
No.
I need to know.
Your dad looks exactly like the crying
indian from those commercials in the
seventies and even got watery eyes by
the way.
Going missing is,
is the braids and the long hair.
Well,
here's something to consider when
someone talks about someone being german
or someone being italian or something
being anYthing,
um,
yeah,
maybe,
but who knows how they got to Germany or
Italy,
17 generations before.
Who knows where any of those people came
from.
All lead back to like some africans you
did not.
You didn't tell them what to tell a
story about.
Well,
from about Cuba,
kimbo slice,
kimbo slice on ultimate fighter guys for
doing that.
Even show this on the air.
So this guy,
I'm not going to mention his name on the
show.
He lost and you can drink all that
alcohol you want in the house.
And there's only at the time there's
only four of us left.
Still fighting.
Roy marcus jones.
I'm mitch,
mitch mitrione and uh,
myself.
That's the for fighting,
right?
So one of the guys,
one of the other guys just hammered,
hammered.
He's lost,
right?
Hammered,
wasted.
All of a sudden this guy gets super
racist in the house and there's a whole
bunch of black guys in the house.
Starts talking out how his wife loves
them because the korean nation and
starts throwing up racial slurs and
throwing up these,
you know the hey hitler stuff heil
hitler started his name on this piece of
paper for me.
All right dude.
Dude,
this isn't getting out though,
right?
I need to know for my own edification.
So he starts doing all this stuff.
I'm sleeping.
I've the biggest fight of mY life.
The next day.
Dana white literally stops us in the
condos.
Listen,
if whoever makes the finale,
we win or not.
You're gonna.
Be a superstar.
it's huge,
man.
biggest season we've ever had.
You guys want to win this fight?
Thank you.
No pressure.
So I'm sleeping and I'm sleeping and uh,
I'm,
I'm sleeping on the ground and I thought
it was a dream.
Kimbo slice and marcus jones and this
and this demicco in this demicco rogers
a comes in my room.
They go,
yo,
shop.
Get up,
dog.
man.
I'm like three large black eyes around
my bed.
Kim goes,
yo man,
this dudes down there talking about our
people.
We're about to jack them up.
I literally thought it was in,
excuse me,
it's talking about our people.
Dog.
Let's go f this dude up and like,
listen,
uh,
you guys realize.
I said I'm,
I'm told I'm not down with the race
thing.
I'm totally down to fuck this dude up,
but you realize I'm not black.
Right?
Kim goes,
he goes,
damn,
that's crazy.
Turn around leaving out here.
That's why I locked shop.
You can't tell what the hell he is.
My I.
Hey kimbo,
that's racist dog while you're just
because I'm athletic and can file you
gotta be black.
He goes,
you could be.
Wow.
That's interesting man.
That's crazy weird situation to be in to
what a trained seller is also an area
nation guy.
Or is he miked up?
All this is going on to.
He's miked up and they have to ask why
didn't they put that on the show?
Oh,
that's not good for rating.
Fuck yeah,
it is.
No,
are you kidding me?
Oh wait,
didn't show any of it,
man.
That guy never fight again.
Diddy,
diddy?
No.
Hm.
Interesting.
Too many clues.
We know people gonna know who this is.
They'll figure it out.
Tough shirt.
That's fascinating.
Bad news six years ago.
Yeah.
They have to make a deCisioN,
right?
Whether you put that oN the tv or not,
we didn't need it though.
The ratings were so high and then you
want to toss some highest ratings ever.
By the way.
Tough 10.
Woo.
Was it really the highest ratings ever?
Nothing's even kimbo slice.
Slice and that crazy.
I'll never forget man,
when you,
when we walked in the house,
right?
Or walk whacking the gym,
you're staring.
And I'm like,
oh,
I don't know.
I don't know any of these guys in wax.
Roy nelson on their for matt mitrione
goes,
we'll look at the fat ass.
I'm off bro.
That's Roy Nelson.
He was suicidal.
He was winning a world champion.
And I have.
It was like 30 fights.
What the fuck?
And roy and matt's like,
that's nothing man.
And then dana was hyping up everyone
going,
do you realize there's 15 guys here?
There's 16 total though.
So we're bringing a special guests.
They hype this thing up.
Everyone's wondering everyone.
I leaned over to roy go,
bro,
you know what?
The route to bring you in and there's
big talks at the time.
Can you imagine if they did this?
I said fear doors to walk through that
motherfucker.
Ross screwed.
I have three fights,
the three fatal disaster and that's why.
That's why when they bring them in and
in watts,
kimbo slice I thought was me fade or
that's why I looked over at manly.
Oh fuck.
Kimbo slice and that's the very first
way people saw me on national tv is me
saying,
fuck kimbo slice.
That's hilarious.
I thought it was gonna be feared or man,
I was all nervous.
I really thought I was going,
oh my god,
somebody needs to talk to you.
why would feed or do the ultimate
fighter?
I don't know.
Maybe they pay them like a million
dollars and he's like,
can you just tear up these kids with
three fights?
you know what's crazy?
Which really see.
That'd be funny.
Crazy though.
is there kimbo slice would get more
readings at where?
Here it's weird.
More people know who kimbo slice was
back then because of youtube,
like the casual persOn then knew who
fader was.
I'll tell you what,
kimbo one of the nicest people have a
very nice guy.
So cool.
Yeah.
Tommy out a fight with a shank.
What damage it rules?
Well,
you leave this arm so they can scrape
that.
I'm going to get the knife and this one
man,
that's dope.
While he was barbecuing,
he needs,
if he's listening,
he needs to open up.
Is a barbecue restaurant.
Kimbos man.
Like I could grill like no one's
business.
He'd make this barbecue sauce and he'd
make his own sauce,
but we put in it.
You have the honey mustard,
all sorts of stuff.
So you just knew it.
He knew what he was doing.
What kind of.
What did he barbecue ribs,
ribs.
I mean cakes.
Oh dude,
he's a chemist.
A chemist.
He was.
He was so cooL,
man.
He was so cool.
Good eaten.
Yeah,
he is.
He is just a natural athlete.
I mean he's just big strong guy.
He's got some serious knee problems,
man.
I Wouldn't come with that.
yeah,
yeah.
I will say he's a natural athlete.
Well,
he's a tough guy.
Tough guy.
Real real knee problems are bone on bone
arthritis in his knees.
That's why I left mma.
Do you try to do some boxing and he
renting?
We wasn't winning,
but he made some improvement.
He definitely made some improvement,
but it was the knees.
His knees were fucked.
You weren't going to get better.
They made some money.
He made some money.
He makes a ton of money as security for
ic mc and reality.
Kings porno,
his best friend is ic.
mc reality kings.
Holla at your boy.
I wonder if they're making any money
more.
is it tough to make money in the world
now,
right?
Like you.
You porn.
Why am I going to pay us the
subscription reality kings?
Yeah,
that's the thing.
You have to be like a real fan to pay a
real cycle.
I think they make money and you went
with a real cycle jacket off about 10
times a day,
your membership,
but there are dudes that become like
fans of a girl just like they become
fans of a band.
Again,
if you'Re my friend and you're a fan of
a girl and you pay for a membership,
lose my number.
If you don't make kids or if you're fan
of girls whose know if you pay for a
membership because you liked one certain
porno star,
you're a psycho.
Where there's some guys that have very
specific tastes like they only like
asian broads.
That's it.
Asian girls only like porno asian and
opportunity employer.
Me too.
I hate.
Yeah.
I encourage everybody.
How about guYs who say they never jerk
off to porn?
Ever lie.
They don't use porn and if they jerk off
it's to their imagination.
Again,
lose my number.
They're lying for sure.
I don't know.
I think some people actually do have a
problem with porn.
They don't like it.
They don't like the fact that they think
that people being victimized in some way
that you know.
I've never met her guys making a lot of
money.
I have.
I definitely.
Really?
Yeah.
I've met people.
Hate said this,
but I watched.
I hate to say this.
I watched.
I watched him lecture.
Please sit dotcom called why I stopped
watching porn and it's really,
really eloquent.
Dude was talking about why it's damaging
and ever since I listened,
it's almost like now that I know
football causes head injuries,
it's literally don't be so well known
and the reason why cast is so good.
You guys balance each other out so well.
I was telling brian,
someone needs to be in the room with him
to let him be him because if you leave
him by himself,
he goes,
by the way,
throw once,
theorized that the reason why this
passion exists.
No,
he called me up because he heard the
year and me doing the elliot health
thing and he goes,
hey bro.
He goes,
let me ask you one of the funniest
people I know so many should show you
for ms dot represent who you really are
on your podcast.
You should see yourself.
Just be funny,
brian.
I hate when you're serious.
Brian.
I didn't say hate when you're serious,
brian.
I said,
you're two different people.
there's you who's really you and there's
you and it goes into lecture mode.
Why am I doing that?
I don't even know why.
Why don't know.
I mean,
I guess probably everybody does it.
I'm sure I'd do it to a certain extent,
but you do it smart people.
You don't know what he did it.
You know what?
He did it on our biggest podcasts when I
resigned my new ufc contract.
I go,
dana,
I'm going to come and sign my contract.
You mind if you're on my podcast?
You did that with dana white in his
office and his office.
Brian.
He goes,
Mr.
White,
where did you get your inspiration from?
Michael?
Let's call him mr wang.
First of all,
I just didn't know him.
No I didn't,
but I didn't know his story for the
story.
I did,
but I didn't know him so I didn't know
whether he had a son to him with me
before.
You're not really like,
you know,
talk to them and now.
Now I know he loves.
He's.
He's gone.
It's gone back to the porno stars
though.
I got a buddy who'S dating what he did
during the podcast,
so like made you a fighter and a kid.
Did you ever talk a little bit?
It was just so like the reason,
the reason why the fighter and the kid
works.
You fuck it up?
No,
no,
no.
I just.
The reason why the fire code works is
because we get serious people,
right?
And we're clowns,
man.
We get them out of the elements.
We make things fun.
We tell him we did a great one.
Ronda rousey recently,
we.
We tell stories with dana.
He was like,
where do you see yourself in 10 years?
No way.
You really don't know what I'm saying.
Questions like that.
What are you at chick?
We have really good arguments that on
the podcast we have serious arguments
about like whether or not ron should
take me or him on this abi apocalypse,
all kinds of stuff.
She's stating the obvious.
That wasn't much of an argument.
I don't want to have a conversation when
you going to provide.
I said,
I said I would take a tim kennedy's,
you know the poisonous mushrooms or
something.
I do.
I know a lot of stuff,
but you would take tim kennedy.
I said,
tim kennedy and I immediately regretted
saying as soon as that,
because they gave a scenario where all
the zombies,
everyone's a zombie,
so it's only you and one other person,
so we couldn't procreate.
Right,
right.
You don't want to take him.
I'm pregnant.
Rhonda.
Saturday.
Yeah.
Rhonda goes,
I'd be a good breeding.
She said,
your army,
you need a breeding.
That's true.
You'd be breeding warriors.
Yeah.
That's a good move.
She's the only choice there a couple of
other choices,
but for you,
that's the only choice.
You can't take.
Tim kennedy can't get them pregnant.
If you were the only two people on earth
and yet to fucking die and leave your
kids to fend for themselves again,
zombies.
You might want to take everybody out in
their sleep and then do yourself.
You might want to fucking end it for
real.
If you're the last two people on earth
and the world is not drown,
swim out as far as you can go.
That's what I say.
just call it out.
Fuck that last person on earth being a
human being.
I know I'm not taking a foxhole.
Youtube.
As soon as things get a little shady,
that's a foxhole.
He shot himself foxholes a war.
We're talking about everybody being dead
except for you in this one chick.
What kind of life is that?
Your baby behind.
You're going to have to fuck your kids.
Do you understand that?
How procreation works.
Someone's going to have to fuck your
kids.
Your kids are gonna.
Have to fuck each other.
No,
that'd Be the garden.
They're going to have to try to survive
and they still might get eaten by
zombies.
Will you guys were given up,
but what are you gonna do?
You're gonna fuck your kids.
You got to keep the reader in a way for
other people.
Okay.
That's what I'm saying.
If you know for sure,
you'd have to know for sure.
Kelly,
yourself or you just figure out what
this is.
I'm here for a reason.
What is it?
Maybe I can figure something out point
though.
You wouldn't really know if you know,
but you two are given up like I am
legend.
No,
I am.
Legend was really like the walking dead,
right,
the camp at the end and everybody was
safe,
but those monsters is way scarier than
the walking dead.
Dead.
Sign me up.
I'm just going to run everywhere they
walk in.
I'm going to run it my mind.
I'm going to cut down to about one 70.
I'm gonna.
have a nice pair of kicks and I'm just
going to run every cardio,
cardio,
cardio.
That shows a little too moody for me.
It's getting ridiculous.
They're eating people now.
It's like they've found a cannibal
fucking colony.
it makes sense I guess,
but there's plenty of deer left to.
It's not like the zombies are eating
deer or they eat a few of them,
but they can't catch him.
I don't understand why everybody gets
guns when he could have a sword.
I mean it's good to have guns,
but that chick never gets fucked with
jacks.
Everything will you run out of bullets
with a sword.
You're just chopping heads off.
Yeah.
You can get a reload.
The rifle.
It takes a couple of seconds.
You gotta fucking 100 zombies coming at
you.
It takes a long time to put 100 bullets
in the chamber.
100 zombies are coming into may take a
sword and start to swing it around.
Fuck yeah.
You take a couple at a tIme and you do
it for about an hour and you got 100
dead until you get,
until you get the zombie.
Like shane carlin,
who knows single legs sambisa don't
learn anything.
They don't even know how to use doors.
You don't pay attention.
You don't even watch that show.
You can't be in this conference.
Please exit the conversation so they
don't even know unscrewed doors in world
war ii,
world war z,
little different.
Those are the scary fast zombie.
Yes.
that's where we're all screwed.
The scary zombies of all time with the
28 days later zombies.
You remember that?
Not only that,
because that's the most likely scenario.
It was z.
They called it rage.
A genetIcally created disease,
modify disease.
A weaponized disease escapes from the
chimps and gets into people and then
spreads like wildfire.
When you think about what rabies does to
to animals and people and people,
people,
if somebody has rabies and you get them
near a body of water,
if they get near a body of water,
they get so hysterical.
You have to chain them down.
Really allude.
That will go.
Why water?
I don't know.
Are you making this up?
Water.
They get crazy.
Like a huge water phobia from.
Oh,
they get afraid of the water.
When's the last time someone got rabies?
Rabies vaccines.
Rabies was,
You know,
I'm talking to now.
People have gotten it really recently.
Been bit by animals.
Yeah.
I wonder if rabies Comes from an animal
and that animal has memories of
drowning.
Look it up.
Look up.
Imagine that shit like we,
we're talking about the,
the,
with the,
uh,
the mice,
the mice giving the,
the remembering the smell with the shop
part of Your brain where you actually go
crazy.
First of all,
you crazy.
That's why the animal will bite you.
TheY go crazy.
They start to drool and they're just
very aggressive.
I'm not,
I'm not making this up.
I had a dog bite me in the ass chicken
had rabies when I was a kid.
Really?
You to get a bunch of shots and guess
what?
I'm not scared of dogs.
you had to get shots in the stomach.
The right dog.
she'd be scared of snakes.
you ever put a.
I put a bite suit on and Afghanistan.
It had dogs and I've done enough.
God,
I hate it too.
Honestly.
Switches it up to see if he's around.
By the way,
if he's around like real military guys,
he takes that shit down.
A few doesn't go up.
Then they'll go,
what do you like?
Silence.
They think I'm a plant.
They think I'm about keto plan.
Like,
no,
they don't think you're a plant.
They think you're a fraud.
You're a plant.
They put a plant on match day.
I lived in the middle east eight years
of my life.
Don't blame me,
but um,
it's done.
Do they release these hydrophobia fear
of water.
Historic name for rabies.
Wow.
It's the historic name for rabies refers
to a set of symptoms.
The later stages of an infection with
the victims has difficulty swallowing.
Shows panic when presented with liquids
to drink and can't quench thirst.
Wow.
So I guess that's what it is.
Like they're scared of water because
they know that they got it in their
mouth.
To suggest I'm drinking may cause
excruciating,
painful spasms of the muscles in the
throat and learn.
Wow.
Suggestion of drinking may cause
excrutiatingly painful spasms and you're
really thirsty.
Yet you're really thirsty.
Great disease,
vaccines,
vaccines.
Yeah,
thank you.
The effect they can shoot you when you
get a bit horrible needles in their
stomach.
You know,
a big giant needles in your fucking
stomach.
This is another reallY bad,
you know the symptoms of tetanus.
Look those up.
Look up the symptoms of tetanus.
That is the worst.
Your whole body seizes up and before you
die,
you're very acutely aware of all the
pain that he didn't.
You see this shit where a jon jones is
requesting that glover to share,
get drug tested?
Oh no.
It's kind of fascinating.
He says,
uh,
agree to a lot of testing.
Well,
this is what he says.
This is exact quote is some fighters you
just know they're not on anything just
by looking at them.
I kind of disagree with that because
like guys like that look like Jeremy
Horn who doesn't look like he's on
anything who have tested positive,
like just because a guy has like a
certain body type doesn't mean that he
can't be on something like got a lot of
guys have tested positive.
I think you're taLking about the
exception there again perhaps,
but those are often the guys that wand
up taking it like,
okay,
here's a perfect example,
tim silvia.
There's tips a lot of folks don't know,
like tim silvia tested hot and before
tim silvia tested hot.
Like look at what he looked like when he
fought rico rodriguez.
I think that tim silvia that beat rico
rodriguez is one of the scariest
heavYweights ever.
I agree.
Tim silvia takedown defense,
great strategies to righthand monster.
They just,
you know,
he couldn't keep that fucking hanging
off the side and I think he was getting
criticized for it and I feel like that's
why I did steroid.
I think you're right.
I mean,
he,
he'd always wanted to sell it to me.
he wanted to look the part,
a little embarrassed of his body a
little bit,
but I also think that it benefited him.
It benefited him physically the way he
would pull up a pull up.
Tim silvia versus rico rodriguez.
That's tim when he was retired from the
ufc.
Now that's tim versus rico rodriguez.
you see that?
That image.
Look how fucking leni wasn't big.
He was dangerous motherfucker and he was
eating rico's leg kicks and dropping
right hands on.
Plus the video.
If you could find the video.
He.
He was a scary guy because he.
Oh,
he also struggled to get down to two 65
for that fight.
He was drawing to get down to,
to see ms dot wait.
He missed wait the first time.
Walked around that I don't know him,
but he was big.
So john saying,
not religious big,
not fat,
but big shoulders and neck.
Such a monster.
Yeah,
exactly.
Clover is on stuff.
Part of glover to share as mystique is
his amazing physical strength and I just
questioned it.
I have no reason to think he's on
steroids,
but I do wonder how someone can be so
strong.
He says,
I'm sure I have fought guys in the past
that were on steroids.
I Think it's pretty well documented.
a lot of people haven't really argued
with it because they know it's true
statement.
I know it's a true statement.
I called dana white and said,
I want glover to take steroid tests for
this fight.
He asked me,
what do you think?
He's on steroids,
and I told him,
I don't know.
I have no reason to accuse him of
anything,
but I would like to be sure.
How can you be mad at that?
You can't be mad at that.
I'm not mad at that at all,
and if he came out and was like,
hey,
glover's on stuff,
there's,
there's tim,
sylvia,
when he fought rico.
Wow.
Look at that big motherfucker to rico.
Had a good guard to man are legitimate
shadow black belt for sure.
Tim silvia was scary back then,
man.
Super scary and he knocked a lot of guys
out.
Man.
A lot of people sleep on tim silvia.
He never gets brought up because he had
sort of a dispute with ufc,
but
head kick,
trade telemann knocked him out and tim
silvia was not a natural athlete by the
way.
This is all from toughness in training
mean pigeon toed.
In fact,
his feet like naturally went towards
each other and here he stuffs to take
down again,
rough sum up on the ground and tim
silvia back then,
you know,
I mean,
you're dealing with a guy who really.
And this is good fucking high guard has
to gun.
Yeah.
And it's like I said,
legit brazilian jiu jitsu,
black belt,
very high level.
Especially at the time,
you know,
at the time,
rico was one of very few brazilian
jujitsu,
black belts in the heavyweight division.
There wasn't a lot of guys.
You see them sitting noguera's guard
risk control.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
He,
uh,
tim silvia at this time I think was one
of the scariest guys.
I agree with you,
but what,
you know,
who knows how much of it was hard
training first of all,
for sure it was definitely some steroids
and fall to me.
He took a look at that,
look at that,
whipped over for that arm bar.
That was pretty fucking sweet.
Have that was pretty fucking sweet.
Spike some gets out of it.
That was a god damn sweet.
Armbar rico had a nest.
The arm bar.
I'Ll tell you what.
Rico had a nice little appearance on a
slow rehab too.
I watched it.
All of it.
Oh no.
With dr.
Drew,
what was he doing?
Drugs.
He likes a little booger.
Sugar.
He likes to have a good time and
partying.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what he likes.
He likes to have a good time.
That tim sylvia rodriguez.
I'm not mad.
Was a fun guy man.
He's a fun guy to hang around with and
there's the righthand he starts.
He's keeping the fight standing.
I'll tell you what,
my only experience with rico,
only time I ever met him,
he was calling in tito ortiz.
We're on the same card.
And uh,
he's looking at the,
at the corner and he goes,
who in the health?
Schwab.
Schwab bank,
gonzaga.
I go right behind you man.
He goes,
your shower?
Yeah.
He goes,
good luck man.
And walks away and I was all,
wow,
thanks man.
Went in there.
I beat the brakes off gonzaga for three
rounds,
striking clinic.
Walked back and he's like,
damn,
great job,
man.
He gave me a hug,
let addict to say that's a fucking
mindfuck former ufc heavyweight
champion.
And I was a fan.
I was like,
oh,
thanks bro.
Who said?
Oh yeah,
that's hilarious.
That's hilarious.
That's really funny.
Funny,
right?
It made me feel like shit.
It's a fucking bad time to feel like
shit.
Did you see this thing?
And tim kennedy fucking tim kennedy,
uh,
at the press conference.
Bisping was swearing at him,
fuck you.
You fuck you.
Fuck this.
We're talking about this.
Bisping legitimately gently makes a
reason to hate you to get ready for the
fight.
Yeah.
Look at this.
Meanwhile,
you know,
who do you have in that fight?
He's trying to scare tim kennedy who's
been to war.
I mean,
brennan man.
He's killed a lot of bad guys.
Like the difference between the fear
that he's experienced and the fear of
like a fight and the preparation for
fight.
This is like a vacation for him.
It really is a rough,
is his mental toughness is not messing.
Listen,
he as as tough as a human being that
gracie had his back,
that was cool,
like was chill on the pitch,
did not care.
Double risk and a lot of combat.
It's a different world man.
That world of firefights in firefights
killed bad guys.
You know,
that's his thing.
Fighting [inaudible] probably not that
much for life and death.
Life and death.
I mean there's some of the stories that
he tells about his firefights and the
things that he can't remember.
How many firefights he's been with that.
Yeah.
And then who do you have in that fight?
A good fight.
Michael bisping has a fucking tremendous
pace that he can keep.
Michael bisping has a fucking 34 hearts
beat per minute.
Resting heart rate that's got some
credits like the shame he is fit as
fuck.
It's the opposite came because cain is a
freak of nature,
man.
He really is a freak of nature when it
comes to his cardio.
You talked to bob cook,
he says it came will take like a month
off.
Get injured.
Come back in,
outwork everybody,
like it doesn't make any sense,
like he doesn't have these like breaking
periods where he has to get back in
shape and some of that is just genetic
slips,
just like some people have incredible
fast twitch muscle fiber.
We've met guys that have never lifted
weights in there.
Fucking gigantic pick cafs and shit like
that doesn't even a.
But look at cane I w I wouldn't say
canes really explosive.
He kinda has that softer body.
Whereas the insurance is going to be
higher.
It's 100 percent genetics.
Yeah.
Well he definitely doesn't have the same
kind of.
You guys like hector lumbar,
right?
Who's just jack to the gills.
His ears have fricking traps.
You know,
you just like swole.
All explosiveness.
Nolan's more explosive than hector.
I agree.
He's the most explosive guy that's ever
fought in mma right up there with melvin
manhoef.
I think he's even more exposed to the
melbourne.
I think so too,
because of the judo and they said,
hector,
your giant swole muscles.
Let's give you the vegan jake shields.
Let's see how this goes.
Fight and fight.
Well,
jagan steroids on its neck.
Jake caught his neck with the last
remaining second fight was hanging on.
Jake's got a god damn vice for a grip.
When he gets that good team,
man,
he tightened that shit up on robbie
lawler.
He tightens that shit up on everybody
and you don't think he's going to be
able to get it.
Like there's a lot of guys think they
can get out of that.
Yeah.
Jake jacobs strong.
Going to train with them on friday and
san francisco.
I'm hector lombard.
Motherfucker hit some judo throws in
this light against jake shields that you
just like a ragdoll them.
If ever there's a reason why.
Hey dad,
why can't I look at this?
Boom,
why watch that again,
just back that up again and just back
that up to that judo toss to back it up
all the way to do this in a world class
grappler like jake shields is just
insane.
Watch this.
He does it so beautifully.
Perfect technique and speed and he's one
of those storms of like athleticism and
technique and really started striking
once he was already an olympic judo.
That's when he started striking,
so he prefers to keep fight standing
just because he's such a fucking
specimen.
Oh,
you won't be a vegan.
I'm going,
I'm going to play that tape for you,
but be here.
Watch this fight.
Like in all fairness,
when you talk about a style like jake
shields is kinda like what we were
talking about could be a worse match up.
Yeah.
They were trying to get rid of them.
Well I don't think so.
They were just trying to give him a
fight that was going to be a really
tough fight.
I mean look,
they just,
it's like if you want to be in the top
10 and he wanted a title shot,
like if he beat book,
what if he caught him with that team the
first round and finished it.
You know,
he's likely in the short list for a
title shot.
If he could finish a guy basically five,
that'd be $500.
You see a guy like hector lumbar,
that style of fucking sprinting.
You can't do it for three rounds.
Can do it for five rounds.
Fight tyron woodley,
woodley.
He's fighting rory.
Rory mcdonald versus willie's a
fantastic fight,
especially if the rory that beat damien
maia shows up.
If rory is motivated and aggressive,
he's gotta.
Get the fuck away from woodland.
That first round though,
buddy and woodley.
It's,
you know,
woodley can move as fast as any fucking
human being in the ufc.
I don't care if the 135 pounds at one
70,
that fucking dude can move like a fast
one.
30 five is that,
that explosive.
He's as big as you can ever get and be a
world class hundred and 70 pounder.
And it's an interesting situation
because,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of like,
uh,
there was debate after I talked about it
on the,
uh,
on the broadcast about this body type.
It has its benefits for sure as far as
explosion and speed,
but it also has a lot of requirements
like for oxygen.
Yeah.
And it's like,
can a guy take it deep into the rounds?
What happens if a guy survives fourth
and fifth?
Because when nate beat them,
they beat him in the fourth round.
Marquardt stopped him in strikeforce
welterweight title fight.
And that's what happened is nate caught
him slowing down and nate,
nate then was before he's had a couple
of these bad knockouts,
like the knockout against hector,
lumbar toughest to get knocked out.
He was when he fought tyron woodley.
You're talking about nate marquardt who
was at his best and but it's back
against the wall too because he had been
kicked out of the ufc,
finally gets back into strikeforce and
he gets a shot at the title at
strikeforce.
It's a big fight and you know,
nate was primed.
It was in his prime.
But you know,
look,
a guy like tyron woodley who is a
superior athlete,
he's just an elite athlete,
is still learning the mma skills.
But it's like what we were talking about
before is that what you're seeing now is
guys who are on an athletic level,
like you've never had the ufc before,
but go back to ufc one and you know,
you watched like,
you know,
some of these guys who as decent
athletes,
good athletes,
you know,
tough guys and had incredible balls to
get into the ufc at that time.
Put tyron woodley and ufc one crazy,
crazy,
crazy.
Ain't taking that dude down now there's
no,
that's not happening at the top.
There's nothing happening.
Evolution of the sport.
Yeah.
I mean if you watch when tyron woodley
beat like jay hiran know one existed
that could move that fast until
recently.
No one existed in the ufc like within
the last five,
six years.
You're starting to see these guys
trickle in that have that kind of
explosion of that kind of athleticism,
that kind of speed.
And hector is right up there.
Heck,
it's like hector entirely.
So it's like as someone who analyzes
fights and it analyzes like there's a
point of diminishing returns,
like what's the best body type?
Is it super muscular like hector
lombard?
Or is it like a carlos condit guy that's
super durable and king last round after
round,
you know,
and the woodley fight,
we saw woodley one me,
he fucked up tyrons knee.
It's a.
But look,
it wasn't really a fight.
His leg fell off,
his leg got hurt in the take down and
then he heard it again when he led
kitchen.
It's not the same as him beating him,
like with no injuries,
but the bottom line is he wins.
He wins j.
You know what I mean?
You can't,
you can't really.
You know what I mean?
Like you can't quantify it the same way
as a knockout or submission.
It's similar to cane versus brock
lesnar.
One guy's just swole to the gills.
The other guy,
if you,
if you saw him with his shirt off,
you're like,
there's no way you're the best except
the fact that,
you know,
would they was still there in the second
round,
you know,
and he's still going at it in the second
round,
you know?
And that's,
you're right,
you're right about that.
There's gotta be a balance like too
muscular has its liabilities and there's
a.
It's like they had that debate about
what's the perfect way for the
heavyweight boxer?
When you get to a certain weight,
you start losing speed and power.
So is it 2:30,
2:40
2:35?
It depends on the body.
You know,
I think bo jackson tell you what number.
Bo jackson at 2:45.
That freaky ashlyn.
He would have,
he would have been probably the,
that's probably the optimal,
the optimal.
And you know what he does now?
Bow hunts.
Yeah,
he does.
That's his shit.
Talked to him about hunting for.
Oh,
I don't know.
About two hours.
Did you live in jackson?
That's what you talked about.
Hunting and he talks about he wants to
talk about.
That's what,
uh,
that's what he wants to talk about.
Like he's obsessed with the way we
talked about football and baseball too.
You better auburn football.
Been winning.
And I said about football.
He said,
he said,
well,
I never left the.
And I played football.
He was six.
He was about six to 2:45
then.
And,
and,
and I said,
why?
He goes,
he goes,
I just scrapped it all and I just go in
there and I'd hear them whispering,
posted the game post in the game.
He was just run through to.
He said,
baseball is way harder than he thought
it was.
As he thought of it as a very,
very cerebral game.
Way more.
So here's bowhunting.
Here's bono's hunting in a tree myself.
Not only enjoys hunting big bucks,
but he loves to shoot a few arrows in
between.
Shoot a few arrows.
How bad are these narrators and these
fucking hunting shows?
Can we get better production?
No,
no.
They get a dollar an episode put
together which you to pay for your
flight on southwest.
You get out there.
The film.
This shit with fucking handycams.
Oh my god.
Fast forward to this so we don't have to
hear it.
Just get to the part where both shoots
it.
Here it is.
Wonder if he can pull back on that pump
after she doesn't feel it.
He's moving nice and slow.
Straight up.
Killer.
Look at boats.
yeah,
that's a light bulb because he's pulling
it back at night.
There's about an inch high.
Oh,
he's in.
Isn't a tree.
Boom.
Yeah.
Hey,
I got an idea.
Next time you bring bo jackson up,
let's show some highlights of him
destroying guys on the football field.
Killing.
That's what he likes.
Now he likes doing that and I'm like bow
jackson anymore because both jackson bow
hunts,
you know jackson,
super boring.
You know what I find is fascinating.
Herschel.
mother fucking walker,
almost 50 years.
Jack his last fight when he was like 49.
It's st by the way.
Take a look at his body,
man against the broncos doing work
shredded.
You don't want to see him sitting in a
tree.
He's a super athlete shooting,
shooting a deer with walkers.
Ridiculous.
He started when he was young.
We'd all,
we'd all be no shit.
Right?
He'd rip people's faces of.
Is that hershel walker?
It's incredible that he had mma fights
in strikeforce.
Deep into.
It's so crazY.
Give you pull up at herschel walker mma
fight.
Get crazy.
Look at that.
Let's thanking god.
He know he's shredded,
but he's fighting billy billy from
kinko's who best to the arena and tossed
on the mouthpiece and whooped his ass.
He was fighting notch guys.
Fight.
Chad griggs.
Who did.
Who did herschel walker fight
you?
I mean,
what are you saying?
Chad?
Greeks is world class,
but I know that's what I'm saying.
He's a very good fighter.
The jet fighter.
Chet griggs is legit.
Don't you?
Shit on him.
You son of a bitch.
I'm not shitting on anybody who's he
fighting here?
Some pretty good guard,
man.
Oh yeah.
That was the dam.
He was big.
Forty eight years old here.
Just completely shredded.
It's just there's a difference in
athleticism,
man.
When you get to this level,
when you get to like a herschel walker,
you're dealing in a hundred first.
All I talked about this in jujitsu,
there's black belts and then there's the
one percent black belts who like booze
shesha haji and yes,
those guys.
So he was to make it to the nfl.
You're the one percent of all football
players.
He was the one percent of one
percenters.
Nfl.
That's insane.
Insane.
And one percent of one percent or one at
a time.
And right now all we watch them on,
strikeforce beat up some poor white guy
who has no business being in the scarf
cars.
Scott carson and greg nagy are the guys
that he fought and he never.
He never followed Chad.
Greg.
So my apologies.
Can you calm down and you over there?
I'll take brian or you didn't.
You didn't.
You fight like some guys that maybe
didn't have the base 52.
Yeah.
No,
he is a monster.
Don't get me wrong.
Still looks great.
Yes.
I would take his bottles of wine,
tea,
our tea.
It doesn't take that.
You sure?
He also says he's surprised also says
that he only eats a bowl of soup and a
salad at dinner as well.
But he eats other stuff.
Oh no.
Somebody says exercise is always been a
religion to him.
Like,
well,
you know,
he also had like a,
an issue or trauma related issue with
like multiple personality disorder.
I didn't.
Yeah,
he had something that was going on.
I heard about this.
Yeah.
It was going on before he had an mma
career and everybody was like,
wait a minute.
If he's had a trauma related,
um,
multiple personality disorder here,
I'll pull that up.
Yeah,
yeah.
Mercy,
multiple personality disorder.
Yeah.
He,
um.
Then they started fighting,
said,
you know,
I'm bipolar.
This is,
let's take punches to the face.
Yeah.
It's cnn Way back in.
When was this article out in 2008.
He,
uh,
he put out a book about it and it was a
book about his multiple personalities
and they believe that,
I believe it's trauma related.
I should probably google that too.
Um,
I don't think that,
I mean,
I'll be honest,
since I've started fighting,
I'm a little one more serious,
little,
little quicker trigger for sure.
If something's getting on my nerves I'm
with on there with them.
I'm,
I used to be super more laid back,
I'd say.
Okay.
Says usually has its roots in childhood
trauma.
Okay.
So that might not mean head injury.
It might mean like abuse child cope with
trauma or abuse.
hm.
I don't know.
And also it has to do with ptsd,
ptsd.
So I guess it is talking about abuse,
about um,
not,
not physical,
not like,
hey,
I'm being treated,
but I mean,
just think about the amount of head
trauma that you have to get playing
football at a high level.
It's unavoidable.
There's no right,
you did it.
It's unavoidable,
unavoidable.
It's really,
it's practice.
It's the practice that does it.
How many times do you think you got
concussions while playing football?
Oh,
five or six and not that many.
I was smart about it.
You're aware of this kind of crazy at
five or six.
This is like a low end for and I played
fullback h back where your.
See if you guys know the position,
you're constantly running five.
It's ridiculous now.
I think about five yards apart.
You run as fast as you can into that.
Go with your head first.
That's what I was doing nonstop.
She christ.
That's crazy.
Again,
why wouldn't someone sent me?
Now I'm like running.
Listen man.
I don't think it's beneficial for your
life,
but you to that guy.
But meanwhile you had success at that.
That lead you to success in college?
Yeah.
Well,
I said to him,
I asked him if he would have traded his
football career and for training and
man,
he said no because you could just talk
now.
Not back then.
There's just the competition level
wasn't.
I'm saying it taught you that you've
learned how to be a dude.
I was training with killers.
You know,
you're talking about some of the very
best athletes in the world day in,
day out competing.
We're competing on the field competing,
so I just learned mental toughness.
You can't pay for that at the time in
2001,
2000.
There wasn't that in mma.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Wow.
Fun times boys.
This is a fun fucking podcast and three
hours just to do it.
Yeah,
let's do that.
Let's do some posts.
Ufc podcast.
We'll do that.
Let's meet in a couple of weeks after
jon jones fight.
Glover.
Okay.
April.
Not this weekend coming up,
but the weekend after that.
That's do it.
Yeah.
Let's do that.
Let's do a post ufc wrap,
right?
We'll,
we'll,
we'll sit down and discuss it and talk
about the undercard and all the shit
that's coming up.
Let's do it and how floyd mayweather.
We get tapped out by ronda rousey go.
We didn't even talk about that.
We didn't even get into that much time.
We have left.
How many minutes?
We can talk about it for a couple.
How much minutes?
We have left.
Five.
We have five minutes.
Do this.
Yeah,
there was a comparison.
No,
it's not even a fight.
If you learned how to have takedown
defense,
he would have to work on that for a long
time.
But,
um,
the uh,
the people online are freaking out.
I was on sports nation today.
Great job.
They asked me great show max kellerman.
That's fucking awesome.
I love that guy.
He's such a good.
The best boxing channel used to be a
rapper.
Yeah.
Him and his brother,
right?
Yeah.
His brother was murdered by a boxer that
they were,
that he was a roommate with.
Yeah.
It's terrible story.
What do you mean the guy killed them?
Killed them with like a hammer.
Yeah.
I don't know the full story.
I read it online,
but,
uh,
rhonda deStroying floyd mayweather.
that would 100 percent happen.
It's again,
like we were talking about like,
I can't play tennis.
I don't know how to play tennis.
I played tennis with someone who knows
what they're doing.
I'm going to get slaughtered.
If you don't know judo and if you don't
know how to grapple,
you don't know.
Take down defense and he will let that
grow.
Clench with you.
You're going flying.
I've seen ronnie get ahold of mma
professional men,
215,
220 pounds tosses them.
These guys have a clue of what they're
doing.
Little loan.
You know what I'm saying?
Floyd mayweather,
who has no clue.
And he's tinY.
Yeah,
he's tiny.
and she's a 150 lb.
Woman or 145 pound woman.
Well she was 35 when she fights.
She walks at heavier than 1:42.
She walks in and she never gets out of
shape.
She's just shredded.
She,
her mom,
her mom's on it,
you know she.
She's on the keyboard all day.
Reject apps.
Forearm shredded.
Just mom was a world champion in judo.
Man,
that's some dna.
That's no joke.
That's also some dna,
just like we're talking about those
mice.
That shit gets transferred,
but it only got transferred to her
because they're sisters.
They're successful in their arenas,
but they're not successful like rhonda
and combat sports.
Well,
maybe They have that inside them.
They just chose not to pursue it for
whatever reason.
Some people,
they get weird shit where they don't
want to do what their parents did and
they get fucking.
But you know what's weird?
Like we talked about jeans.
How about arms swartz,
sneakers,
kids?
What do they look like?
Shit.
They're all skinny.
You think a sworn statement?
You think they're gonna?
Be jack.
Why aren't you doing squats?
You're not doing anything with your
glutes.
Your hamstrings.
Your back is very narrow.
If you want women to be sexually
attracted to you,
you want to come inside them,
deal.
You can live.
Your body is going to live it strongly
to lift weights and you got to run.
You got to do steroids.
Is that his daughter started,
cutie.
She's a cutie pie.
Look to try and find the sons that I
think there are actors.
I'll tell you that on the podcast.
I'll tell you the one who got the girl's
attractive girls.
Attractive hope.
It's great.
The one the the,
the kid who had with the made the little
mexican will do that.
Yeah.
He got the good gene.
He looks like conan,
comBination austrian and mexican.
geez,
what did I say?
Fuck man.
Anyway,
hey,
I'm,
I'm sure these kids are tapped for the
record.
I'm sure the kids separate town shame
his fucking son because he's,
I'm sure he's super talented.
I'm just saying he's not gonna win mr
olympia.
That's all I'm saying is that maybe
would have you started lifting and
taking steroids a lot of time and
steroids.
Yeah.
Nobody's winning.
Mr m jeans jeans are okay,
but he probably doesn't work out at all
me.
if he's pretty jacked,
I'll tell you what the little mexican
guys can be in your next olympian is
jack.
He probably doesn't get a chance to hang
out with his real dad very much either,
and that's probably a bit of a mind
fuck.
He's in the weight room.
Angry doing dead lifts.
You know,
anger can go along way kettlebell
whenever he makes those noises,
that's a good arsenal to lift.
Pumping is better than calming.
You ever hear that from pumping iron
pump coming.
I love that movie.
The fighter and the kid working with
people.
Get it.
I tuned soundcloud.
Yep.
Fox sports.
One website where we need a website
because now that we're on fox or are you
bitches living in?
I know now we're living.
We had.
We do have a website,
but now that we were on fox sports,
fox sports one for sure to get that
right.
We.
We did not itunes find us on itunes,
find the kid,
fall.
Brian and I asked brendan shop at brian
callen.
We post all sorts of videos on
instagram.
What's up with them censoring your
podcast?
That's wack as fuck.
You know,
this is the internet.
I agree.
Box is the big social.
Look how much fun we had today.
Look how much fun you guys had been buck
wild fox needs to just put a warning on
this podcast.
Take the reins office.
Brian and brendan are fucking awesome.
They wanted to be on the internet,
but they wanted sensor.
That is so hilarious.
It's like we want to rate it x movie,
but with no fucking right.
It's dumb.
We're,
we're,
we're bringing up a lot of these
issues to them and drop it.
We're having a serious talk with.
I have real sponsors that are like real
companies.
You guys can have real sponsors too.
It does.
You can swear.
It's just words coming out of your
mouth.
Right?
You know,
just don't show any pornography or
anything really ridiculous.
I agree.
Come on fox.
brian,
don't wear those tight ass jeans.
Don't show they got you gone a little
bit.
Don't show mr.
Sharp your cock,
your cat jack.
Get your dick in boston one time and
said,
I know you didn't have.
Thanks to legal zoom.
Thanks for sponsoring the podcast.
Go to legalzoom.com
and use the code word rogan in the
referral box for mars leavings.
Thanks.
Also to naturebox,
uh,
go to naturebox.com/rogan.
That's naturebox.com/rogan.
And save 50 percent off your first box.
Thanks.
Also to [inaudible] dot com.
go to o n n I t use the codeword rogan
and save 10 percent off any and all
supplements will be back tomorrow with
david seaman.
And uh,
I'll see you guys in atlanta this
weekend.
show sold out.
Me and joey diaz and will also be there
for the fox night at the fights the ufc
on saturday night.
Travis browne versus fabrizio verdugo.
I want to see that donald cowboy cerrone
versus edson barboza and liz carmouche.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Bye.
Big kiss.